[Musique]
gilles babinet bonsoir bonsoir vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle thinker view nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement donc je
m'appelle gilles babinet
je suis un entrepreneur dans le
numérique un peu moins maintenant
d'ailleurs actuellement je suis
vice-président du conseil national
numérique puis
j'ai eu une fonction qui était d'être
digital champion de la france auprès la
commission européenne le conseil
national du numérique c'est quoi digital
champions c'est quoi et entrepreneurs en
numérique ça veut dire quoi alors je
commence par le dernier c'est le plus
ancien donc entrepreneurs numérique mais
j'ai monté un sombre de société au début
pas dans le numérique d'ailleurs ma
première boîte dans le bâtiment après
dans le design après dans numérique
plusieurs sociétés cédées start up
typiquement et puis là je fais moi je
suis plus un peu business angels dans ce
domaine et puis depuis plusieurs années
pas mal d'années en fait 8 9 ans je
m'intéresse aux politiques publiques
au sein d'un institut montaigne où je
travaille pas mal depuis 8 9 ans
j'ai d'abord fait un premier passage au
conseil national du numérique donc quand
il a été fondé
après j'ai été à la commission
européenne m'occuper de ce programme
digital champions je vais revenir et
puis je suis revenu au conseil national
du numérique depuis un an et demi donc
je suis vice-président conseil national
numérique son rôle c'est de conseiller
le gouvernement sur
sa stratégie au sens large et c'est très
vaste c'est à dire que on peut
s'intéresser à comment fonctionne
l'administration en interne c'est
l'objet de notre dernier rapport qui est
sorti aujourd'hui
tout comme on peut s'intéresser
aux enjeux de contrôle du du discours de
haine sur les réseaux sociaux ou encore
à des enjeux d'éducation comment forme
les élèves au numérique à l'éducation
nationale par exemple on a déjà une
question sur internet qui me dit
business angels c'est quoi
ces deux maîtres d investir dans des
start up en ce qui me concerne plutôt au
début c'est à dire
dans des start up qui ont un deux trois
ans assez tôt je suis pas un fonds
d'investissement donc je mets des petits
investissements et puis je les mentors
je les aide à se développer
on va on va parler start-up d'etion
surveillance de masse n sur les réseaux
sociaux et tout un tas de choses gaffe a
souvent été numérique et plein d'autres
sujets connexes est-ce que la start up
nation c'est pas un peu du bullshit pour
personnes qui veulent choper de la
subvention escale à elles m'ont
réellement iliad et des licornes qui
vont émerger de sap ou alors pour être
très clair moi je suis content et
subventions je pense que c'est un truc
qui sort la tête des entrepreneurs dans
le mauvais sens donc on devrait
supprimer ça les subventions le plus
possible voilà
ce dont on parle c'est plus
d'investissement de capital risque ou de
voile à de faire en sorte que ce sont
souvent finances assez simplement les
entreprises start up nation
enfin oui je sais pas qui a inventé ce
truc là c'est peut-être m'accroche pas
quoi en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que il vaut mieux
faire le numérique que le subir et c'est
partant de ce postulat que je pense que
c'est mieux d'avoir nos startups que de
dépendre des guerres femmes
américain
souveraineté numérique
une autre question est ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire un peu plus sur
l'institut montaigne
l'acier montaigne c racing qui va avoir
20 ans puisqu'elle a été fondée en 2000
qu'on souvent on cite comme un think
tank libéral aux gens qui me disent ah
moi je dis ok citez moi un think tank
qui travaille sur
la sortie de prison sur l'éducation dans
les zones précaires sur
des sujets vraiment d'inclusion et qui a
fait ça depuis très longtemps voilà et
moi si c'était un think tank qui
n'avait pas ses préoccupations je
travaille pas pour quelle roue
l'institut montaigne il a un rôle
important parce qu'il est influence sur
les politiques publiques on essaie de
mesurer par exemple le nombre de
préconisations qu'on fait qu'il passe
effectivement dans la loi et c'est assez
significatif voilà c'est je crois que
c'est 50 % au bout de trois ans quelque
chose de cet ordre là donc c'est un rôle
d' influence mais une influence qui est
d'abord à l'abri des lobbys on est
indépendant de tout intérêt particulier
par exemple on refuse d'avoir
financement qui est supérieur à 1,5 pour
cent qui vient d'une seule entité c'est
très répandu auprès de centaines je
pense qu'on peut dire pas loin milliers
de personnes aujourd'hui
et puis on essaye de neutraliser ça
aussi dans la composition des groupes de
travail faire en sorte qu'ils aient pas
quelqu'un qui de façon évidente
représente un intérêt particulier le
budget de fonctionnement de l'institut
montaigne c'est combien
alors il yal ainsi montagne et puis
derrière il ya différentes associations
comme justement sortir de prison agir
pour l'école l'institut montaigne en
tant que tel c'est je crois 6 millions 5
agir pour l'école me semble c'est deux
millions voilà l'idée c'est que d'ici un
ou deux ans on soit à peu près la
périmétrie des 10 millions c'est pas un
objectif en soi mais l'institut
montaigne est de très loin le plus gros
think tank français est l'un des plus
gros think tank européen on va on va
commencer avec quelque chose qui nous
tient à coeur le projet de l'article 57
ce que vous en avez entendu parler
alors c'est celui qui a changé non on
parle lequel l'article 5 qui permettrait
de donner les pleins pouvoirs à bercy
pour espionner sur les réseaux sociaux
faire là mais il donnait à le fisc
effectivement non seulement j'en ai
entendu parler mais je me suis exprimé
dessus alors pas dans un avis du ce est
nu mais à la radio
il ya un problème de proportionnalité
c'est en fait le vrai moi j'ai pas de
problème à attraper les gens qui
fraudent le fisc voilà le problème que
j'ai c'est quand on attrape surtout les
petits et pas les gros et ce truc là le
truc évident qu'on voit c'est le bon
coin par exemple les gens qui sont un
peu au-dessus de la limite inférieure
et qui s'arrondit ses fins de mois comme
ça et un petit problème donc ça c'est un
souci je pense voilà donc moi je me suis
exprimé là-dessus le on en a reparlé
dans une plénière du sénat du conseil
national du mérite hier je pense qu'il
n'est pas exclu qu'on saisisse du sujet
et il ya un consensus au sein du ce et
nîmes à cet égard bon alors ça fait des
années qu'on se connaît donc je vais te
tutoyer
tu connais tu as connu quelques pas tout
j'ai pu bosser d'ailleurs que j'ai pu
sauver et
on est en train de nous mettre une
camisole numérique sur la population
avec cette surveillance de masse on
n'est pas en train de coincer la
population avec un ramassage et de l'ère
numérique alors le c'est un sujet
évidemment
moi on analyse et c'est une analyse je
pense qu'il déplaît à beaucoup mais peu
importe c'est soit on fait rien et on
dit il faut pas numériser l'état parce
qu'il ya un risque royen important le
problème c'est que dans ce cas là en
gros ce qu'ils vont faire le service
public c'est les gars fin il n'y a pas
tellement d'alternative à sa et soit en
dit ok on numérise l'état mais par
contre vous ne la fait pas à l'envers et
on crée les institutions qui sont
inclusive
typiquement ont fait en sorte que si on
fait une identité numérique se soit pas
l'intérieur qui disent voilà ça marche
comme ça et puis c'est une black box
sister l'intérieur ministère l'intérieur
exactement et c'est nous qui décidons et
spec il n'y a pas de l'audit habilitées
du code il n'y a pas de droit de recours
en cas de problème ou en tout cas c'est
nous qu'ils ont leurs cours voilà donc
ça c'est mon sentiment il ya plein de
gens qui disent ouais t'es un gros naïfs
si j'étais vraiment convaincu d'être un
gros naïf je serai plus en france en
fait je pense qu'on peut le faire je
pense que l'europe la france ces quinze
modèles alternatifs moi je suis pas très
à l'aise avec ce qui se passe dans plein
de pays et je pense qu'on a encore la
chance du week-end aux etats-unis
typiquement c'est une société qui
presque inclusive et qui a fait la
surveillance de masse à jean eu
d'ailleurs qu'ils continueraient tout à
fait enfin si en suisse ne donne un
salaire de continuer à être un problème
voire peut-être même s'amplifier
voilà et donc donc je crois profondément
aux institutions je pense qu'on peut
design et au delà du code des
institutions qui créent des
contre-pouvoirs pouvoir judiciaire qui
en charge de défendre la liberté
individuelle par exemple et donc il faut
ensemble trouver les design qui vont
faire que l'on pourra à la fois
faire des services qui fonctionneront
bien qu'ils seront pire on cherchait
justement les gens qui acceptent pas à
ces trucs là et puis qui deviendront pas
aux rois lien
on parle de dégâts sur internet imagine
je me fais déchirer directement
jeudi la première fois je t'ai
rencontrée j'ai vu j'avais prendre des
rotules à lui
petite parenthèse
pourquoi pourquoi une société telle que
les états unis passent en mode
surveillance de masse pourquoi c'est
pour faire du renseignement économique
c'est parce qu'ils ont peur de leur
population c'est pour faire du
renseignement à l'extérieur c'est pour
mettre en laissent leurs alliés leurs
futurs ennemis c'est pourquoi ces lois
le lobby militaro-industriel way à roger
leloup droit de spots et tout le monde
c'est un pays qui a une histoire très
forte avec la violence donc il continue
et cette violence une de ces façons de
s'exprimer
c'est leur enseignement de masse et une
certaine
radicalisation de gens qui n'ont pas
grand chose à voir les uns par rapport
aux autres il ya un rêve américain rêve
d'inclusion qui est en train de
dérailler depuis au moins une vingtaine
d'années et je pense que la technologie
n'arrange pas les choses
est-ce que tu as lu le papier du temps
qui dit les pays-bas bâtisse un état de
surveillance pour les pauvres oui j'ai
pas lu ce papier là mais j'ai vu sans
doute un extrait de sa passe est
effectivement
à c'est pas cool et c'est parce qu'il
faut faire évidemment pas ce que
racontait le papier
que en gros tout ce qui était droits
sociaux etc c'était conditionné et que
ont rassemblé les données pour pouvoir
dire aux gens vous vous comportez pas
bien on vous dégage du système
est-ce qu'en france on est en train de
prendre le chemin de la chine avec la
reconnaissance faciale
moi je veux pas le voir comme ça en fait
c'est avec le notent les citoyens lui
mais sous surveillance h 24 avec les
caméras de vidéosurveillance doucement
appelé vidéoprotection c'est
non je pense pas qu'on veut qu'on prenne
sèchement la reconnaissance sociale en
france ben au début enfin on en est au
tout début je rappelle il ya al islam
qui est un prototype qui a en gros et
d'avoir un passeport sur son smartphone
voilà pour ceux qui voyagent beaucoup on
n'a pas rare qui existe depuis plusieurs
années après même pas d'ailleurs paraphe
on a montré à bien la quille moi ouais
ça fonctionne pas bien et pourquoi pas
ce que parce que ces gars là à
l'intérieur ils disent l'écouter c'est
nous l'état c'est nous qui décidons
c'est nous qui design on et puis si vous
n'êtes pas content c'est façon il n'y a
pas d'alternative quoi ça n'est pas
comme ça que ça fonctionne et il faut
sortir de ce modèle là maintenant moi je
voyage beaucoup je trouve que par afs
est plutôt utile pour passer les
frontières et que ses services étaient
empreintes ya pas très longtemps des
envies ouais beaucoup de ce possible
j'espère qu'on a fait bon usage
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
on peut faire un design qui fonctionne
voilà c'est juste pas celui tel qu'il
existe aujourd'hui nous on travaille là
dessus on travaille là-dessus au
numérique et j'espère bien que quand on
se prononcera
ce qu'on dirait on a rencontré la
quadrature il ya encore quarante huit
heures on était plutôt assez à l'aise
avec ce qui ressortit de cet échange
vous
il faudrait leur demander mais je pense
qu'en tout cas d'un mois ce qui m'est
revenu c'est que c'était un échange
assez constructive des deux côtés
après on n'est pas d'accord sur plein de
trucs elles ont eu eux ils sont contre
la reconnaissance tout court dans l'état
pas moi mais il n'y a pas encore de
consensus dans le c je m'exprime un
titre individuel pas aussi du seigneur
quand je dis ça
et je pense que par exemple cette
technologie
c'est un peu comme la géoloc moi je me
rappelle très bien il ya 20 ans il ya eu
un débat sur la géoloc et à l'époque les
incisions public était pour l'interdire
géolocalisation via ouais c'est trop
dangereux à l'intérieur puis la cnil est
revenu à dessus et a dit on va
l'autorisé mais il faudra à chaque fois
validée chaque fois qu'on est
géolocalisé et puis arrivé l'iphone qui
a balayé ça parce que là la x était
tellement forte que c'est devenu
ridicule
et en plus
et voilà il est donc je pense que
il faut pas d'une part à se dire que les
usages vont nous dépasse et ça c'est un
problème et 2 que c'est les usages des
plateformes qui vont nous dépasser et
donc plutôt que de laisser faire
l'intérieur où les plateformes il faut
se faire à l'intérieur ouais il faut
créer une troisième voie qui est de dire
voilà le design de référence et c'est
comme ça qu'on peut faire un truc
inclusif qui nous rendra pas ridicule
dans 3 6 ans je reviens sur la
reconnaissance faciale reconnaissance
faciale pour s'authentifier auprès des
institutions c'est ça c'est comme ça
qu'on nous l'a vendu
quand je vois les nouveaux radars qui
ont été installés sur les routes
françaises les rades à quoi aurait l'air
je vois le truc direct tu vois le truc
bien avec déjà une technique l'air
chinoise on devrais même dire c'est plus
la plaque de la bagnole mais c'est toi
direct la session bon mais ça c'est
fâcheux dire nous on est tous des
citoyens c'est nous qui votons c'est
nous qui décidons en quoi c'est comme ça
qu'est ce que les alors le conseil
national numérique sa valeur
consultative vous êtes tous bénévoles
c'est de faire cesser en gros le plus on
écoute et enfin - oui oui on sait bien
c'est là on est écouté mais ouais non
c'est pas vrai il ya le conseil national
numérique moi je j'ai eu plein de cas où
je me suis frites et parfois même avec
l'intérieur
en tuant le soufre amant
je me souviens d'un échange avec le
dircab du ministre il ya quelques années
ils ont retiré le projet de loi je te
serai pas te dire sur quoi je n'étais
même plus haut c'est nîmes d1 l'époque
j'étais moi voilà mais j'avais pris la
parole sur ce sujet je je pense que la
ministre à l'époque ça doit être
excellent le maire et je me souviens
très bien d'un échange très violent avec
le dircab
c'est pas que moi et tout le monde était
d'accord là dessus sur le fait que ça
collait pas quoi mais mais voilà ils
sont sensibles à la pression et puis
c'est la démocratie il faut y croire
sinon on laisse tomber quoi il ya un
membre de notre communauté qui nous dit
on vote non décide de rien c'est pas
vrai c'est pas vrai je veux dire moi je
passe beaucoup de temps et je passe du
temps gracieusement à me battre pour mes
idées
et puis des fois je dis ok je suis
vraiment pas d'accord avec ce truc là il
ya un débat il ya eu discussion et ça
change quoi et et cesser voilà il faut
du temps le prince et sa s'est donné
beaucoup beaucoup de temps et donc
cesser voilà la base du truc c'est
de bosser de construire
des idées qui se repose sur
les principes forts d'être capable de
les défendre et voilà le conseil
national numérique c'est avant tout les
gens qui sont là
parce que ils ont un discours un passé
qui fait qu'ils ont une crédibilité
c'est pas que les représentants des
telcos des grandes boîtes il ya des gens
démons qui sont maintenant quoi
tu dis faut du temps est ce que tu
trouves que notre gouvernement prend le
temps d'informer ses citoyens prend le
temps d'étudier les répercussions de ce
type de lois ou de ce type de matériel
ou est ce que tu trouves pas que ça va
trop vite qu'on comprend pas assez le
temps et est ce que tu penses pas aussi
que la population est relativement
passive par rapport à ce qui se passe ou
à cette transition à cette mutation
numérique de la société on dit toujours
la plus grande forteresse de ceux qui
nous gouvernent c'est l'inertie des
peuples ouais
je fais pas de politique de comptoir ce
qui m'intéresse c'est les trucs sur
lequel je bosse et là je peux te
répondre tu vois un tic de comptoir ça
c'est trop général c'est pas je sais pas
répondre à ça tu vois je sais jugé moi
je suis pas politologue je suis personne
numérique peu de réponses sur des sujets
là dessus j'aurai un avis qui sera la
vue de tout le monde quoi tu vois c'est
sûr mais sujet tu vois par exemple par
rapport à ça mais là on a un sujet
important c'est l'identité électronique
la reconnaissance faciale
et on est en plus face un ministère moi
je dis je pense il ya deux trois
ministères qui sont difficiles à traiter
il ya les affaires sociales sert les
hôpitaux et ça papa de leur fait parce
que c'est un ministère qui traitent avec
des fonctions qui sont à l'extérieur de
l'état
les partenaires sociaux en l'occurrence
et donc c'est très difficile de
numériser ce truc à la justice parce
qu'ils sont partis sur super à la bourre
et qu' ils n'ont pas d'argent exactement
ils sont voilà sur ce truc là et
l'intérieur à l'intérieur c'est
compliqué parce qu'ils ont une culture
de l'état c'est nous on est l'état
régalien et donc c'est difficile c'est
compliqué et moi j'ai un gros problème
j'ai travaillé avec france visa sur
france 2 il ya quelques années truc il a
été pliée le gars qui s'occupaient de ça
il est parti en dépression il est sorti
du truc et le truc c'est de fermer voilà
parce qu'un nom il se rendus compte
qu'ils avaient pu avoir le contrôle
discrétionnaire sur la façon d'attribuer
des visas voilà je te le dis cash c'est
comme ça que ça s'est passé et voilà et
donc et moi je veux dire je vais pas
dire ouais on va faire un peu de violon
pour amadouer les gares etc non mais je
pense qu'il ya plein de gens
responsables aussi d'ailleurs chez eux
et c'est comme ça et peut-être ça va
super bien se passer peut-être pas et si
ça se passe pas bien je le dirai et je
serai pas le seul à le dire ici
question est ce qu'on peut faire nos
gars femme est ce que on a la capacité
par exemple de résister aux états unis
quand les états unis décident de quitter
ou un mail est ce que si un jour il
décide de couper google si ainsi un jour
il décide de dvd référence et la presse
ouais alors oui et non c'est que les ton
ami
je peux répondre comme ça je connais
plein de gens qui sont des copains et
google c'est ça non non je trahis par
google c'est pas comme ça que je le vois
assez j'essaie de rester un animal à
sang froid et donc mon sentiment c'est
google est trop gros et doit être
démantelé tu vois comme ça maintenant si
tu veux l'affect ne doit pas rentrer
là-dedans serre si je suis pro ou anti
atlantiste c'est pas le problème le
problème c est ce que google crée des
distorsions sur les démocraties sur
l'innovation c'est comme ça qu'il faut
l'analyser et si je l'analyse ça et que
je me rends compte que la réponse est
non et ben walkom tu vois c'est le vrai
problème c'est l'émotion il faut sortir
de l'émotion il faut essayer d'avoir une
réponse technique et c'est difficile
quels sont les sujets où il ya trop
d'émotion alors
il y en a plein je veux dire deux mots
zone 3 l'identité la reconnaissance
faciale
les gaffes à
jet pack est ce que je pourrais donner
d'autres comme sujet
cent et cent et 3 bon à mon avis sur ce
truc là je voudrais répondre à ta
question est ce que l'europe où la
france peut faire des gaffes ah oui et
non non parce que ça existe déjà refaire
un moteur de recherche au 21e siècle
c'est débile refaire un réseau social au
21e siècle c'est probablement pas une
très bonne idée par contre on peut
dépasser ça typiquement si je prends
amazon que j'ai pas cité c'est pas
impossible qu'on puisse dire ok ce truc
là est en train de détruire c'est un
truc du 20e siècle ça va chercher des
trucs en chine ça les ramène en europe
ça fait une empreinte carbone de malades
on va faire l'amazone l'économie
circulaire et on va créer une
compensation des externalités que
procurent les autres plateformes pour
mettre tout le monde au même niveau
l'europe veut faire ça voilà ça c'est
von der leyen elle a dit maintenant si
vous importez des trucs en europe et qui
a des externalités social
environnemental vous allez payer pour ça
ça veut dire derrière qu' on peut
complètement repensé des sites
l'économie totalement nouveau avec le
numérique
il ya quelqu'un qui me jette un tricheur
sur notre inertie
l'extraterritorialité du droit américain
quand on est un français qu'on utilise
un produit américain on continue on
utilise le dollar au contenu on utilise
d'autres choses est-ce que ça devient
gênant ouais alors ça c'est vrai que là
moi j'ai du mal à garder mon sang-froid
sert qu'on a un énorme problème j'ai vu
cet extraordinaire vidéo de son
interview sur alstom s'est tassée
décontenançant et on voit ça et on se
dit bon on a un problème le dollar c'est
un énorme problème c'est une blague de
dire dès que vous transactionnel en
dollars vous êtes soumis à l'ensemble du
droit américain c'est du foutage de
gueule cercle ils nous ont noyé sous le
dollar et maintenant il nous explique en
gros on est américain quoi donc on a on
a
problème là dessus c'est pas pour ça que
il faut dire
70 ans de relation forte il faut jeter
ça à la poubelle c'est compliqué on est
dans une situation qui est compliqué
avec trump objectivement qui pour moi
est un personnage qui me correspond en
rien aux valeurs qui m'intéresse mais
derrière il ya toute une administration
qui essaye de recoller les morceaux
toute la journée un qui font ça sans
cesse et trump est pas éternel quoi et
malgré tout on a besoin
même avec les états unis multi
multilatéralisme donc on peut pas les
jeter de but en blanc voilà et donc il
faut avoir une approche ipr rationnelle
hyper construite point par point y
compris sur les plateformes je te piège
un peu c'est quoi les valeurs qui
t'intéresse
l'inclusion mais aussi la modernité
voilà c'est ça m'intéresse de faire une
société équitable mais de rester au
19ème siècle ça m'intéresse pas parce
que je pense que la technologie c'est
avant tout un facteur de progrès ça a
fait éclater de rire tout le monde quand
on dit ça mais on a quand même changé le
monde grâce à ça je veux dire mon
arrière grand père mon grand père il est
mort à 38 ans parce qu'il a chopé froid
dans la rue voilà et donc c'est débile
mais on se dit toujours à waimes et
attend c'était un autre siècle c'est le
progrès qui a fait la différence avec ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui et les
technologies numériques potentiellement
c'est un truc de dingue
tu me fais un marchepied pour ma
prochaine question est ce que tu as vu
passer
le bientôt scandale ou peut-être pas
avec google sur son sur son projet qui
s'appelle night in game où ils
collectent des informations médicales ou
prévoient d'une quarantaine d'hôpitaux
il ya
le wall street journal qui a sorti salle
enfin ça je connais assez bien on en
parle ouais on peut en parler alors il
faut savoir que ça fait quinze ans que
les plates formes pour ça elles le font
beaucoup moins aujourd'hui qu'elle le
faisait avant alors il ya 15 ans moi
j'avais un copain qui bossait au
bellevue hospital qui récupère et des
data en masse
sur facebook utilisé l'épidémiologie et
tout le monde était super content il a
fait les publications sur 18 avec ça et
ça posait des problèmes à personne voilà
mais il ya eu tellement de personnes et
aux cons non non il est des publications
avec les personnes qui lâche et la
randonnée ah si si si il avait un
obstine il avait sens interdit d'y
enquêter en opt-in bookeen ça veut dire
opt-in opt-out ça veut dire des gens qui
avaient autorisé qu'on utilise leur
donner en sachant comment ça
fonctionnait et c'est maintenant ça
serait prenant plus possible d'ailleurs
facebook actuellement essaye de libérer
des données à des fins de recherche et
n'y arrive pas parce qu'il cherche à
créer le cadre juridique qui soit
sécurisant pour les gens qui sont
propriétaires des données et on irait
flux en fait sur ce truc là donc on a
jeté le bébé avec l'eau du bain cercle
si on avait filé ces données n'ont pas à
cambridge et à l'éthique à mai à la
recherche on aurait pu faire des trucs
extraordinaires
tous les sociologues tous les gens qui
font de la médecine peuvent faire des
trucs extraordinaires juste un truc tout
bête les données de localisation on
prend une ville comme par exemple
dreux on comprend la data et regarde ce
qui se passe on va pouvoir quasiment
dire il ya x % de personnes qui sont en
situation de dépendance il ya expansion
de chômeurs et à aix pour cent de ça et
voilà les endroits où il faut mettre des
dispensaires faut mettre des agences
pôle emploi c'est le potentiel de la
data et on n'a pas besoin de données
personnelles pour faire ça mais on a
besoin d'un cadre et d'une gouvernance
de la data qui est évidemment
extrêmement forte sinon ça part en
vrille pour faire ce truc là aujourd'hui
on est presque plus capable de faire ça
c'est un problème est ce qui est ce que
le cadre ce fameux cadre ces fameux
garde-fous
quand on voit dans les gaffes hayatou
temps l'armée américaine qui traînent
dedans
là tout le temps c'est clair un fonds un
fonds d'investissement de l'armée
américaine qui traque dedans il ya dans
le conseil d'administration des anciens
ou des futurs gendarmes et deux dents
est ce que la société civile
n'a pas de gros risques en fait parce
que c'est l'armée en face
à l'or est un truc étonnant moi j'ai
perso mais bon c'est une appréciation
j'ai moins peur des militaires que des
forces de police sur cette affaire parce
que c'est pas les mêmes problématiques
et ces voix là alors après je parle
peut-être de ce que je connais de
l'armée française qui est un peu
différent annonce de la france tout coup
oui c'est vrai aussi de l'expérience de
la france la france tout court mais
le problème de 2,2 des états unis c'est
que cette affaire s'est fait ensemble et
ça moi je le dis tout le temps si les
gens ne se rendent pas compte à quel
point il n'y aurait pas eu de gaffe à
sans complexe militaro industriel
voilà ça j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur ce
sujet quand je dis beaucoup j'ai
beaucoup travaillé sur ce sujet j'ai
fait des voyages d'études exprès aux
états unis j'ai dû en faire cinq ou six
où j'ai été rencontré des
administrateurs de la darpa j'ai été au
caltech plein plein échange etc il ya
aujourd'hui encore plein de programmes
de recherche qui sont financés même pas
par la darpa parle dit woody en direct
dans très nombreuses universités et
d'une certaine manière même si à une
vraie indépendance des chercheurs
il ya une influence de facto quoi sur la
façon dont ça fonctionne puis le fait
qu'après ces chercheurs ont peut
potentiellement les recruter les faire
passer dans des start up qui vont est
elle même financée par des fonds
d'investissement
marine oui par exemple bon voilà je suis
pas rentré dans la construction précise
sam et recourent soit c'est bien
question internet en parlant des armées
françaises est ce qu'il peut dire de
leurs méthodes bout de ligne de collecte
des informations non c'est trop tard
l'armée française a fait de la collecte
d'informations pas à ce que l'armée
faisant je sais pas répondre à ça
l'armée française non pas du tout est ce
que l armée française c'est un peu la
ramasse par rapport aux gaffes
américaine est ce que le fait qu'on ait
du windows un peu partout le conseil
national numérique dis attention l'armée
quand même alors c'est difficile pour
moi de répondre ça parce que d'abord je
suis pas un spécialiste de ce sujet et
j'ai eu des conversations avec des
militaires et je ne suis pas agréé
secret défense mais il ya un accord
tacite qui est que je ne révèle pas ce
qui m'a été les échanges que j'ai eus je
dirais mon sentiment c'est que celle du
mouvement le faire parler ouais allons-y
non mais c'est voilà c'est normal ça
existe aussi un c'est mon sentiment
c'est qu'il ya une prise de conscience
de deux choses qui sont importantes
d'abord d'un problème de compétence qui
est
et qui a eu des conséquences sur
l'architecturé même du système
d'information et ça ça j'ai trouvé ça
assez intéressant de voir une grande en
fait comme enjeu la neige et les autres
aires la transparence gens qui m'ont dit
voilà comment on voit notre système
voilà ce qui est ce qu'on essaye de
faire et j'étais assez sensible à ça il
ya un deuxième aspect que j'ai trouvé
intéressant c'est que l'armée est
consciente du fait que elle ne peut plus
faire tout seul et que c'est pas les
grands opérateurs industriels il faut
aller chercher c'est plutôt un monde
informel voilà
et ça j'ai un peu prêcher pour ça il ya
quelques années et je vois
qu'aujourd'hui c'est devenu beaucoup
plus évident dans leurs esprits surtout
alan sinon 26 mai lan 6 et pas l'armée
c'est c'est quelque chose de dit
autonome voilà mais même si c'est très
vertueux je veux dire qu'au 26 26 et
nationale de la sécurité des systèmes
d'information
et
c'est une agence qui rattache au premier
ministre n'ont pas à l'armée il ya
effectivement son nombre de gens qui
sont issus de l'armée
dedans et c'est une nation qui me
semble-t-il est assez respecté parce que
elle a une très bonne culture elle a une
culture depuis qu'on a ou pas
alors je ne connaissais pas dan si c'est
pas pour par qui a créé l'année s'il y
avait quelqu'un avant lui un autre avant
lui quelqu'un d'accord donc
effectivement moi je connais j'adorais
les cravates guillaume poupart et je le
respecte beaucoup et je pense qu'il a
une vision très forte et je pense que
cette vision à des petits points de
frustration parce qu'il aimerait aller
beaucoup plus loin et je pense que
le conseil national du numérique va
s'intéresser à ce sujet c'est un peu un
scoop mais voilà ça devrait ça devrait
être le cas
on a eu des échanges récents là dessus
c'est pal en silane si c'est peut-être
l'administration la plus vertueuse à
l'égard du numérique en france
alors il ya sur internet on parlait
beaucoup là et on en reparle aussi est
ce que tu as vu ce qui se passe en
espagne en ce moment concernant la
collecte de données la géolocalisation
pendant huit jours ils vont un petit peu
ce se faire spots et parleurs et armes
de rouelles non j'ai pas vu sa commande
sur tout le territoire pendant huit
jours ils vont flic est géolocalisé tous
les gsm
tout un tas de choses mais à quelles
fins je sais pas enfin posé la question
à bas il ya un log de toutes nos
localisation chez les opérateurs de
télécoms aujourd'hui et sont obligés de
le garder pendant un an je crois à nom
me semble
on va revenir sur ce sujet là donc ça
existe déjà et ghilas et quand vous
allez contre dans un tribunal
je dire de bas étage de faits divers il
ya un gars sur trois c'est hallucinant
enfin moi je suis rentré une fois là
dedans
et c'était incroyable quoi il y avait
deux gars en l'espace de une demi heure
où le jury mais c'est marrant parce que
vous me dites que vous étiez pas là mais
votre téléphone lui il était là donc ils
se baladent tout seul face était c'était
dur quoi c'était vraiment
le sait nîmes est ce qu'il sait d'une
formule des préconisations concernant
ce qui se passe avec les renseignements
par exemple la loi de programmation
militaire non est-ce qu'on pourrait le
faire mais on l'a pas fait
on a beaucoup de sujets donc on va
travailler sur
ce sujet de la cybersécurité
on n'a aucune comment dire il n'y a pas
de on n'est pas là à se dire ouh là là
ils vont pas aimer si on fait ça c'est
pas comme ça qu'on bosse c'est on se dit
est ce qu'il ya un sujet qui est
vraiment important sur lequel il faut
qu'on bosse parce qu'elle est urgent de
libertés publiques parce qu'il ya des
enjeux de souveraineté parce qu'il ya
des enjeux de performance économique ou
d'autres encore on a un débat entre nous
on dit on y va on n'y va pas voilà la
souveraineté les préconisations les plus
fortes que vous ayez émises de faire la
digital nation non mais en fait la
nation digital
la souveraineté c'est reprendre le
pouvoir sur nos données et donc avoir
des plateformes chez nous qui traite les
données c'est un aspect essentiel voilà
et
de fait
ça passe par le fait d'avoir des start
up ça peut être vu par certains comme
candide ça passe par le fait d'avoir des
gens qui traitent de la data ici et
beaucoup voilà et ce qui se passe c'est
plutôt parti pour aller dans la bonne
direction voilà on va avoir des licornes
des unicorns d'aidé qu'accorde petit à
petit on va avoir un écosystème qui
serait la plus grosse différence entre
nous et les états unis c'est le temps
ils sont partis dans les années soixante
dix nous on est parti dans les années
2013 2014 si le temps mais regarde les
chinois wen chinois ils sont partis en
97 ça va j'ai travaillé sur ce truc là
il avait à l'époque ministre un ex miss
de l'ex tronic qui a été de façon courte
premier secrétaire du parti communiste
liang chi minh et qui allie on va mettre
le paquet là dessus ils ont fait ça et
quand je dis ils ont mis le paquet ils
ont mis des décuple de l'argent qu'on
est capable de mobiliser et donc là il
arrive à un niveau effectivement
extraordinaire on ferait pareil vu le
capital humain qui en europe je pense
qu'on y arriverait très bien sur
internet la france peut-elle se protéger
de la chine numériquement
mais oui bien sûr je veux dire on peut
on est souverain on peut faire notre
modèle mais
c'est avant tout du débat moi moi mon
plus gros problème c'est de discuter
avec des gens qui ont une culture
numérique très faible comme les
ministres oui mais pas que dans les
actions partout je discute pas tous les
jours avec des ministres ça m'arrive de
temps en temps mais c'est le patron
je sais pas d'une
grande mutuelle voilà une mutuelle ces
trucs parapublic voilà ils gèrent des
centaines de milliers des millions de
comptes et il se rend pas compte que il
a de la data qui a une très grande
valeur et qu' il est très peu productive
parce qu'il a des processus
administratifs dans tous les sens et que
en gros il va se faire dès intermédié
par par un acteur digital qui sera
capable de mieux faire du diagnostic
des interactions médicamenteuses
du remboursement etc etc tu parles
d'assurance tu parles de mutuelle est-ce
que tu parles avec des directeurs de
banques
oui
est-ce qu'ils sont un peu stressés avec
le fait que facebook commence à lancer
sa banque que google à sa banque comme
leur monnaie non non non le plus gros
stress pour eux c'est les taux bas ça
les a détruits pour l'instant très
fortement
sur ce truc là
court ou moyen terme à court terme ils
sont stressés mais ce qui sont plus
rentables et à moyen terme ils sont
stressés parce qu'ils vont vraiment cool
et ils vont emmener tout le monde avec
eux ou je sais pas moi je déteste sur la
futurologie c'est pas mon job quoi c'est
je ne sais pas c'est en tout cas ce qui
est certain c'est que les gains de
productivité sont pas encore exprimés
dans cet univers et ils vont s'exprimer
fortement voilà donc ce qu'on appelle la
robotique process automation qui est
l'intelligence artificielle ans et
process
de bureaux de bureaucratie de production
administrative s'est pas encore très
présent et ça va le devenir
donc
ils vont devoir traiter ça disparaître
je pense pas parce qu'il ya nous on voit
les métiers de guichet donc on a chacun
une carte de crédit en poche et on voit
bien que ces services là ce serait
peut-être plus facile à être intégré par
par google ou un facebook
d'abord moi ce que je pense c'est que
ces gars-là faut les empêcher de grossir
parce qu'ils sont déjà trop gros voilà
donc vouloir dire non la banque c'est
pas possible voilà c'est comme ça c'est
mais il faut le faire de façon
structurée il faut pas leur dire on vous
aime pas donc on va faire comme ça faut
leur expliquer pourquoi il faut être
capable de défendre en terme d'anti
trust si on n'est pas capable de le
faire faut pas le faire parce que il
faut une base de droit c'est comme ça on
est dans un monde moderne monde moderne
c'est le droit et au delà de ça je pense
que si les banques perdait ça il ya
quand même beaucoup de métiers de la
finance qui continue à exister qui
représente aujourd'hui la majorité de
leurs revenus
c'est quoi la majorité de leurs revenus
c'est quoi c'est l' hyper frequency
trading c'est quoi c'est la banque
d'affairé officiellement interdit la
paix offre s'est grossi trading c'est
très régulée en tout cas ça nous donne
qui nie les dark pools aussi alors ça
c'est pas les banques le shadow banking
c'est à l'extérieur des banques
justement et ça c'est un problème pour
les banques c'est non mais shadow
banking le shadow banking c'est un tiers
qui va faire du provisionning et qui va
émettre de la monnaie voilà c'est jeu
je crée un
par exemple comment ça s'appelle litchi
c'est du shadow banking voilà maintenant
ça a été acheté par une banque mais
c'est assez marrant de dire je fais un
pool et puis après je leur verse une
fois que ces débloquer quelque part vous
faites de l'émission monétaire quand
vous faites ça comme tipi non je connais
pas tipi meiway surnom
les crypto monnaie la chine commence à
se positionner sur les crypto monnaie le
venezuela essayé bon donc ça saute
les gaffes un vol aussi faire de la
crypto monnaie le bitcoin est ce que les
états
voient il faut qu'il le fassois il faut
interdire gafa de le faire parce qu'ils
ont trop de puissance dans la data et
donc moi je me suis prononcé tout de
suite contre libre dès que ça a été un
ancien lendemain j'ai en hurlant et
heureusement tout le monde a suivi donc
ça c'est bien
il faut que les états fassent des crypto
mais parce que c'est un instrument très
complémentaires des monnaies souveraine
elles peuvent être adossée à leur
monnaie évidemment donc garanti par leur
bonnet elles peuvent flatter de façon
indépendante
c'est pas très clair d'ailleurs ce que
la banque centrale européenne a dit et
la chine à cet égard mais c'est un
instrument supplémentaire de
souveraineté et donc c'est bien de le
faire à cet égard
explique nous un petit peu la crypto
mais qu'est ce que t'en connais ça
marche comment quelles technologies
à moi j'ai pas été liant les white paper
de la banque centrale européenne mais je
pense que il faut que ce soit sur une
technologie de l'autre chaîne à mon avis
et
[Musique]
après c'est pas pareil parce que c'est
une bonne chaîne qui peut être privé
ou partiellement public est ce que tout
le monde peut la mine et enfin il
faudrait que se poser la question c'est
vachement compliqué de répondre à ça
il ya peut-être pas de problème est ce
qu'il ya des mineurs externe mais en
tout cas il ya une gouvernance
pour ce soit ça reste une monnaie
souveraine
qui continuent à être
lié à un pouvoir politique en fait sinon
ça n'a pas de sens alors explique nous
ce que ça veut dire miné
minet c'est faire du hcc être capable de
garantir
le fonctionnement de l'intégrité des
noeuds de la blood chaîne
en ayant du calcul qui est décentralisée
qui est fait à différents endroits
question internet la guerre numérique
sera t-elle selon vous la justification
de l'augmentation de la surveillance des
citoyens
ouais alors je vais leur formuler pour
voir si j'ai bien compris mais en gros
on dit mme bah si on laisse pas les
gaffes à faire ça va être bâti x c'est
un peu comme ça que je le comprends et
donc comme il ya les batiks sceller bien
sympathique c'est du côté asiatique et
du mégaphone côté américain c'est vrai
les batiks c'est les quatre plus grosses
entreprises du numérique chinoise et les
gaffes un gars femmes moi je vais dire
trouve que ce serait quand même plus
correct dire les gars femmes c'est les 5
plus grandes entreprises américaines et
est donc on va se dire en fait pour être
efficace il faut qu'on crunch de la
donnée de façon très transversal et donc
pour le coup comme on est l'état et
qu'on crunch plein plein de données on
est capable de martyriser les jantes ses
hommes
ban en fait je pense que c'est encore
une fois c'est à dire l'état c'est nous
quoi et 6 il a vraiment l'impression que
l'état sait d'où mais il faut que ce
soit comme ça sinon marrant nous quoi ca
on arrête c
on abandonne tout je te prends je te
vois et moi je fais dire je passe
peut-être la moitié de mon temps à faire
des affaires publiques à m'occuper de
privatisation de la dépit de la
française des jeux moi c'est une
connerie à françois de jeu je m'en fous
je sais pas assez il peut y avoir un
régulateur je sais pas c'est à dépêcher
mais encore une fois tu vois je sors de
mon espèce de conte fée de compétences
et en sorte de zone de confort broquet
perso je pense qu à l'épée c'est une
connerie parce que en fait on fait de la
cavalerie c'est à dire que
on dit je prends du cash tout de suite
et
tout ça c'est pour améliorer mon bilan
dans dix ans on a pu le revenu récurrent
que ça génère quoi il sans doute
après est ce que
moi je pense que l'état ne peut pas tout
faire
voilà je pense que là où les tailles
voilà pourquoi une différence entre
commence pas le truc de jeu la française
des jeux à la française des jeux et et
adp parce qu'en fait je pense que l'état
est bon dans le temps dans les
infrastructures de temps long on le voit
assez souvent quand on privatise une
autoroute les ponts ce matin il ya plus
d'argent pour les réparer ou les gars
disent on va les réparer mais vous nous
refiler des années plus ça a été le
débat je crois sur terre ça certaines
autoroutes récemment je mon pénis bon
voila c'était
quel est le ministre qui a pris cette
décision c'était une grosse connerie
voilà c'est on voit il ya eu une étude
qui a été faite par un think tank qui
n'est pas l'institut montaigne je crois
d'ailleurs américain qui déjà en fait on
aurait gardé ce truc dans le public ça
aurait rapporté trois ou quatre fois ce
que ça a rapporté à l'époque et puis on
aurait peut-être des infrastructures qui
aurait fonctionné aussi bien ou mieux
j'en sais rien donc donc le ton nom
c'est l'état c'est ma logique c'est
comme ça et là j'ai encore une fois je
sors de nos mains de mon domaine de
compétence il se trouve que je
m'intéresse un peu à ça dans le cadre de
ce que je fais à l'as tu montagne mais
je préfère revenir dans mon domaine
alors dans ton domaine cambridge
analytique à quai sur internet cambridge
analytica il en pense quoi
mais qu'est ce que je peux repenser ses
caisses que c'était cambridge hannity
cas pour ceux qui n'ont pas suivi le
problème c'est un tiers une boîte privée
indépendante de facebook qui a compris
comment on pouvait extraire de la data
de façon intelligente de facebook
travers d'opérations de jeu on pose des
questions alors c'est des jeux super
addictif où tout le monde a envie de
répondre pour savoir comment ils ce
score sur certains
jeu et puis cette donnée est aspiré et
va permettre de pousser la publicité
politique en fonction de ce que j'ai
répondu au jeu et on cherche des gens
qui sont capables de changer d'avis on
sent qu'ils sont influençables au
travers de ce qu'ils répondent aux jeux
est manifestement ça a été utilisée
massivement dans le cadre du brics it
est et ce qui est vraisemblable c'est
que facebook
même si nice a ils ont vu le truc
d'assez loin ils ont fermé la pays quand
ils s'en sont rendu compte mais ils
n'ont pas vraiment voulu regarder en
détail c'est la même chose pour la
publicité politique ils ont refusé
d'intégrer la publicité politique moi je
trouve ça pas normal voilà alors que
twitter l'a interdite
normal
parce que warren donc l'une des
candidates à l'élection présidentielle
elle a acheté pub je te suis
complètement délirante
qui n'auraient pas dû passer s'il y
avait eu un autorités de régulation même
même privé appartenant à facebook
regardez les pubs avant de les poster il
n'aurait pas posté ce truc là et donc on
peut poster n'importe quoi voilà et moi
je suis désolé distordre
les élections
par de l'argent ça me pose un petit
problème la structure fing c'est quoi
je ne sais plus ce que c'est que la
senteur fini il faut que tu me rappelles
modifier la perception dans une élection
ou des choses comme ça oui c'est ça
c'est ça ce terme là bas c'est
exactement ça
ces astres aussi mais je fais
l'étymologie du nom c'est excellent ben
voilà donc on a on a un problème qui
paraît il et on a
l'état d' élections qui arrivent
c'est c'est pas réglé c'est pareil en
termes de les ingérences de pays
étrangers dans d'autres pays avec le
numérique
qui croient qu'ils croient pas ça fait
vraiment ses preuves à ce que ça à
prouver réellement quelque chose qu'on
pouvait vraiment influencer une élection
c'est difficile d'être définitif à cet
égard effectivement
je dirais que je suis très suspicieux
je pense que
là le premier pays on pense à la russie
curieusement plus qu'à la chine qui a
plus de moyens à cet égard
je pense qu'ils ont une culture de
renseignement qui est extrêmement forte
et d'influencés aussi qui est très très
forte
voilà
donc bon il faut qu'on se défendre
sur ce plan ce qui pose que le problème
du soft power ou plutôt du char power
c'est à dire le problème c'est que quand
on commence à rentrer dans les messages
à émettre des messages on fait ce qu'on
appelle la propagande et à propagande ça
n'est pas digne d'une démocratie on peut
pas faire le propagande on allait enfin
qu'on a fait la preuve en dessous de moi
la guerre d'algérie
voilà c'est séméac et de la propagande
en ce moment
politique en france
oui enfin encore une fois là tu me
ramènes en dehors de mon cercle de
compétences erp sur une appréciation sur
la politique générale pour savoir qui tu
es aussi ouais bien sûr mais
moi j'ai en fait quand j'ai un avis je
le donne il ya plein de chance sur
lequel je suis pas à l'aise parce que
j'ai pas d'avis définitif sur cela tu
vois c'est est ce que le gouvernement
fait la propagande
oui comme tous les gouvernements je
pense moi j'ai des souvenirs des
gouvernements précédents je sortais de
mon fauteuil à chaque fois qu'il
s'exprimait tu vois assez
et en ce moment de la
françois hollande nicolas sarkozy voilà
c'est
pour parler de ceux qui m'ont intéressé
parce que j'étais impliqué dans le sujet
voilà c'est
jeu tu vois si je prends un exercice qui
a été très critiquée que les grands le
grand débat
on a dit il fait une campagne électorale
gratos et tout ça
macron là je parle macro mais a
contrario
il ya un mec qui a été je suis désolé je
le dis un peu vulgairement par les eaux
boueuses pour une fois tu vois c'est moi
ce que je veux et est quand même très
encadrée ouais mais ça a au moins eu le
mérite d'exister je ne cesse de dire moi
je ne cesse de dire tous les ministres
devraient
passer du temps avec des vrais citoyens
de façon récurrente
voilà on retire les galons et notamment
pour la construction des politiques
publiques et notamment pour les
politiques publiques qui visent cette
fameuse diagonale du vide où il ya un
désengagement de l'état sur lequel un
sujet sur lequel moi je m'intéresse
vraiment beaucoup
au travers du numérique on devrait dire
ok on va se poser la question la
dépendance monsieur le ministre faut pas
nous la faire j'ai une demi heure parce
que j'ai un truc plus important à faire
non on va passer une demi-journée
ensemble et on va réfléchir ensemble
avec avec un urgentiste un designer des
sociologues décodeurs
des parents de personnes dépendantes
des vieux et qui vivent dans les
territoires et on bosse voilà et je dis
ça parce que mon ancien métier c'était
designer il ya 20 ans moi j'avais une
agence de design et c'est comme ça qu'on
résout les problèmes c'est comme ça
qu'on résout les problèmes aujourd'hui
même le fait le sait nîmes a sorti une
note où on fait cette recommandation ont
fait cette recommandation voilà donc et
une fois qu'on a fait ça on est
bouleversé et on voit plus les choses
pareilles
revenons à la propagande comment on fait
pour résister la propagande numérique
je pense que le le premier truc me
semble-t-il c'est
de muscles et l'inde si c'est à dire
lundi si pour le moment son mission
c'est la cybersécurité voilà mais je
pense qu'il faut qu'on ait des sondes
des signaux faibles
algorithmique de différents types et je
pense
c'est à discuter réfléchir ça passe par
un second cercle d'acteurs alternatifs
qui sont à l'extérieur voilà et ce qui
m'a beaucoup intéressé dans différents
domaines
c'est d'observer que il ya des white
rate qui vont dire écoute tu m'emmerdes
moi ça m'intéresse pas bosser pour
l'état mais sur cette cause en
particulier je vais bien bossé pour toi
qu'est-ce que ses ouailles tête c'est
des gens qui sont
des très bons codeurs on appelle ça des
hackers en d'autres termes qui
comprennent les enjeux de cybersécurité
et au delà les enjeux d'un flux ans et
qui sont prêts à consacrer une partie de
leur énergie à traiter certains
problèmes voilà tu as fait du blanc va
faire les noirs et les gris seco les
noirs n'ont alors les grilles c'est
intéressant parce que si tu peux être
white hat et black hat en même temps
enfin c'est à dire tu peux dire écoute
moi sur cette lutte là g7 dézinguer
parce que ça m'intéresse pas ce que tu
fais et donc j'ai envie de lutter contre
toi et puis sur tel autre lui tu es
lutter avec toi voilà je dis ça parce
que je connais quelqu'un qui est dans ce
cas de figure essama au début beaucoup
intrigué j'ai dit mais c'est
complètement ce qu'ils ont quoi et
maintenant je suis au contraire très
consistant avec la façon dont je vois
les choses
donc cambridge hannity cas on a éclusé
le sujet tu veux y revenir dessus pas du
tout
non je si je vais revenir dessus mais je
suis sûr qu'il y en a cinq ou six autres
qui n'ont pas été trouvés tient pas été
trouvée à juin alors j'ai pas non je
sais pas qui c'est mais mes hommes il se
trouve que
pas trop dire ça mais je connais
quelqu'un qui a bossé a assez haut
niveau dans un mégaphone et qui m'a dit
qu'il savait qu'il y en avait d'autres
voilà donc
regretter tel quel
alors je suis en sait pas plus en
l'occurrence et il a vraiment j'ai dit
tout ce que je sais je sais pas mais si
je sais que c'est en europe et qu'il ya
du don et le pays je ne sais pas
franchement je ne sais pas ces gros se
structure petit sur thur non j'ai à peu
près dit tout ce que savait vraiment où
tu me parles bien plus non j'ai dit tout
ce que ça va d'accord on va parler de
l'europe
question de l'exo 7 les états européens
sont ils conscients des enjeux ils sont
ils prêts à investir massivement pour
contourner les gars femme
ça n'existe pas les états européens
certes c'est un truc que moi j'ai mis du
temps à comprendre mais l'europe c'est
des états qui sont souverains qui sont
chez eux et un peu comme les white hat
ou les black cats qui vont dire ok ce
sujet important par poêle non non je
compare pas mais ce que je veux dire
c'est d'un point de vue de la logique
ils peuvent s'associer sur un sujet où
être traditionn sûr que si simplement
sur la logique ou simplement pour des
intérêts oui ils ont des intérêts
divergents
je prends l'allemagne qui est un pays
que je connais bien
l'allemagne
allez on va le dire de façon un peu cash
a été un boulet dans le numérique ces
dernières années
pourquoi parce que à chaque fois qu'ils
avaient une initiative un peu forte ils
disaient ouais mais faut investir et moi
la règle des 3% c'est important donc on
n'investit pas où ils disaient ah ouais
mais si on fait ça si on s'oppose au
cloud acte ça va fâcher les américains
et on vend plein de bmw là bas donc on
va pas le faire
etc et puis les chinois pareil voilà et
donc là où date explique sue c'est le
cloud acte c'est un accord qui nous
permet de continuer à faire fonctionner
les gaffes 1 en europe pour faire simple
un fait poutine dans un cadre légal et
et de fait c'est un accord qui est
compliqué parce que
il permet d'investiguer quasiment tout
ce qui est une des pannes anti
américaine donc si un disque dur il a
marqué un design et aux états unis pis
ouais on peut rentrer dedans et on peut
remonter la data j'exagère un tout petit
peu mais on n'est pas très loin de ça et
il ya beaucoup de flou là-dessus cercle
quand vous discutez avec
les gens du cloud azure de microsoft si
on veut dire mais non faut pas vous
inquiéter puisqu'elles sont peut crypter
et ses chiffres et
voilà et et en fait on a un problème
quoi voilà donc il faut qu'on ait un
plat de souverains faucon et 7 c en jeu
voilà c'est ça notre souveraineté c'est
nos data quoi mais il faut pas faire
voilà après autant
mais non ça commence tout juste ça
commence tout juste je veux dire c'est
l'avancée technologique hills etats-unis
ont pris
aujourd'hui il ya plus de brevets sont
déposés dans toute l'europe que aux
états unis ou en chine il ya plus de
publications de référence dans
l'intelligence artificielle comme aux
états unis ou en chine il ya plus de
gens qui sont sur tencer flou comme aux
états unis ou en chine etc etc on
exporte de la matière première brute ce
qu'il faut c'est que on la transforme et
la transformer ses avoirs nos
plateformes à nos
extraordinaires
ralentir ça parle pas d'outil moi ça me
permet à part entière moi je ne suis pas
chez moi dans mon salon il fallait
m'appeler ouais mais il ya un an 2008 je
crois un truc comme ça tu vois c'est la
partie de bout ils sont partis
mais parce que moi à l'époque c'était
une mini start up je ne savais pas je
savais qu'il était peter tilt je pense
qu'il était déjà dedans et c'est
peut-être même comme ça que les ai
rencontrés mais ça me tire ses coins
ralentir c'est un je vais le dire de
façon très différente de la façon dont
on dit pour moi c'est un fantastique
outil de data crown chine et de
visualisation
qui fait que ce qui est compliqué
devient simple voilà en général on dit
que c'est un outil
d'intelligence
économique basé sur la data
moi je les ai vu marcher dans une loi
qui était pro lens a plus grand chose à
voir et à l'époque ce que j'ai vu c'est
un outil de data visualisation c'est
donc je modifie des variables et
j'arrivais à faire ressortir du signal
du bruit voilà maintenant
palan tir a fait beaucoup de bruit parce
que c'est financé par intel qui est le
fonds de la cia
parce que leurs premiers clients ce sont
les grandes agences
américaines
qu'ils utilisent massivement parce
qu'ils ont largement fait partir la
rumeur que ils ont attrapé ben laden en
utilisant cet outil d'ailleurs ça je
pense que j'ai été l'un des premiers à
le dire parce qu'il se trouve que un peu
par hasard j'ai croisés dans un déjeuner
aux états unis ces gens que j'avais vu
avec un journaliste américain et que la
conversation a eu lieu devant moi ils
ont animé alors ouais vous avez utilisé
le truc et que c'était en fait plus en
2016 un truc comme ça j'ai plus quand
ben laden a été attrapé mais c'était
quoi il ya quatre ans entre enfin voilà
et donc c'était assez marrant en quoi
c'était intéressant mais pas lent tir en
particulier fait des gorges chaudes
parce que il utilisé par la dgse et l'a
déjà si ma compréhension de ça c'est que
les risques comme ça oui donc il ya un
risque
évidemment d'avoir une backdoor d'avoir
des data qui remonte en réalité non pas
re porte dérobée pour sort des roms est
exactement ma compréhension c'est que
non parce que pas l'entière n'est pas
connectée à internet dans la façon de
l'utiliser à la digestion déjà si donc
il est scellé il est dans un univers
s'il ya des puits de données il ya un
data l'est qui appartient à des récits
dans lesquels ils font ils sont en batch
ils sont pas connectés au réseau et
donc tu vois pas très bien comment ça
pourrait être un problème c'est ennuyeux
qu'on ait pas cet outil chez nous qu'on
puisse pas le développer en france mais
dans cet usage n'est pas de problème pas
l'on tire alors c'est mieux de dire ça
parce que tout le monde aimerait bien
que je sorte un truc en direction
d'arles ou je sais pas quoi mais non
on reviendra sur la surveillance et sur
la gestion des données pour faire
d'interception
on va parler écologie et numérique ah
ouais c'est un choix sur les problèmes
d'énergie à venir est ce vraiment la
priorité quand un innocent c'est la
question posée après désolé
l'écologie numérique les data center qui
sut saint-maur du courant le l'empreinte
numérique de tout ce qu'on utilise les
métaux rares
les terreur qu'on va massacrer en
afrique ou en chine l'empreinte
écologique du numérique typiquement le
seigneur me vient de sortir un avis là
dessus
voilà et donc après c'est difficile
parce que typiquement ce type d'avis et
très transversal c'est difficile de
mettre en oeuvre
ces avait parlé de lannoy pas qu'un peu
des choses comme ça moi et bien sûr ou
un pack pacte
c'est une loi extrêmement vaste qui
englobe beaucoup de domaines mais qui
concerne notamment l'énergie
les enjeux de transition énergétique
il ya des tas de sujets qui concernent
par exemple is ova l'isolation des
bâtiments
mais il n'y a pas de volet spécifique
sur le numérique si ce n'est sur la
recyclabilité des équipements
écologie numérique qu'est ce qu'ils vont
faire une question des préconisations
alors donc le contact c'est quoi ces 380
millions de tonnes de déchets
électroniques par an c'est aujourd'hui
une estimation aux alentours de 9 % de
l'énergie électrique est consacré
à tout ce qui est informatique au sens
large
des hypothèses que ça monte à 20%
notamment avec les gpu
voilà et donc ça devient un sujet de
préoccupation
le
et plusieurs choses qui doivent être
dites d'abord dans les choses positives
ya
une amélioration de la performance des
data center qui est très rapide qui est
supérieur à la loi de moore en fait donc
il ya vraiment une amélioration très
importante et il n'y a pas de linéarité
entre l'augmentation de la puissance de
calcul et la consommation quand on
double la puissance de calcul la
consommation elle augmente je sais pas
d'un tiers ou quelque chose comme ça
voire peut-être moins encore donc ça
c'est un point qui mérite d'être dit
deuxièmement et quand même des travaux
importants sur le recyclage de l'énergie
des datacenters
notamment en mettant du logement à côté
et en chauffant ces logements
l'hiver dans en utilisant l'énergie
reste l'enjeu que les datacenters et 365
jours par an je vais qu'à voir les
chauffages qui tourne pendant l'été
c'est pas très cool donc on reste quand
même avec une partie du problème puis un
autre aspect qui est important c'est que
si on était intelligent et qu'on
n'utilisait convenablement le numérique
on est capable d'avoir une incidence
très forte sur l'environnement les smart
grid ses smart parce qu'il ya du
numérique dedans et la transition
énergétique
elle ne peut se faire qu'avec des smart
grid
si demain on utilise les batteries des
tesla et autres véhicules électriques
pour la nuit pouvoir avoir l'énergie
quand il ya plus de soleil eau
distribuée qu'il n'y a pas de vent
potentiellement ça peut fonctionner moi
je pense que c'est une perspective al
assez long terme mais ça marche avec
beaucoup de technologies numériques et
puis il ya d'autres aspects qui sont
intéressants avec le numérique bla bla
car c'est de l'offset en fait cercle
plutôt que d'avoir dix voitures qui vont
à lyon ben on a deux voitures avec cinq
personnes dans chaque voiture enfin je
caricature mais c'est un petit peu
l'idée de ce genre de chauffer rebond
avec les blablas car et ainsi de suite
oui il ya possiblement des effets
rebonds
enfin par exemple le taux de remplissage
des camions ça c'est des études de la
commission européenne ben en 2000 il
était sur le longue distance de 18 %
aujourd'hui il est de 31% et ça c'est
grâce aux plateformes numériques
alors ça c'est en ville je crois non
c'est ça ça ces chiffres là c'est pour
la ville le taux de remplissage des
camions pour la longue distance il était
peut-être de 25% maintenant il a passé
les 50 % tu parles de perspectives long
terme tu parlais de recyclage est-ce que
vous parler du fait que les terreur
c'est super polluons l'extraction du
rein quand tu vois tesla qui sécurise
son approvisionnement
terreur de quand tu vois la bolivie
tomber alors qu peur j'appartenais à
bolloré l'heure la plus grande mine de
lithium était entre les mains de bolloré
je sais pas si c'est encore le cas
aujourd'hui mais il avait beaucoup
parier sur ces blu ray car là ça n'a pas
eu le succès évidemment qu'il escomptait
je sais pas s'il a gardé le contrat
d'exclusivité qu'il avait sur ce cette
espèce de mine de lithium extraordinaire
bon mais mais en fait là dessus la
réalité c'est que il faut quelque chose
d'hyper simple c'est les externalités
immédiatement
payé et après compenser sûr que je vais
chercher des terrains là dessus on
mesure les externalités elles viennent
en plus dans le prix de l'iphone du truc
et après ça j'ai une obligation de
recyclage et on se sert
d'eux
au-delà de ça de cette extériorité pour
faire des compensations c'est pas
suffisant mais c'est nécessaire question
d'internet qui n'est pas du tout
déconnante d'ailleurs qui va te paraître
peut-être un peu déconné tour de prime
abord mais qui n'est pas du tout
déconnante dans un monde entièrement
numérique que pense-t-il de la
protection contre les tempêtes solaires
par les gouvernements tempêtes solaires
de type de celle de 1859 quelles
protections existent combien de temps
est-il nécessaire pour mettre en place
un système informatique ouais ouais
c'est
durcissement n'est contre les chocs
radioélectrique c'est un vrai sujet j'ai
pas particulièrement basses et là dessus
je sais que ça existe et je sais
d'ailleurs qu'il existe des armes
militaires
qui sont extrêmement efficaces
parce que the mp6 un mois exactement
je crois qu'ils ont été utilisés en 2007
en syrie quand les israéliens ont été
bombardés une amorce de centres de
centres nucléaires en syrie 2007 ces
vieux 1 ils ont neutralisé la défense
anti-aérienne syrienne avec ce type
d'armes au départ et donc on est hyper
sensible par rapport à ça parce que
d'abord c'est un coût supplémentaire
c'est un poids supplémentaire donc pas
pas s'encombrer de ce genre de choses et
je pense que il faut qu'il y ait une
réflexion là dessus en fait
là où c'est intéressant c'est que c'est
un élément de souveraineté et qu' il
faut commencer par la chose militaire
et puis petit à petit des escalades et
ça tapait sur les olives et seniors les
organisations d'importance vitale et
petit à petit roeulx descendre jusqu'à
un certain niveau mais oui ici si le
monde venait à se compliquer quand se
fâcher avec corée du nord
ouais par exemple
qu'est ce que peut faire la corée du
nord d'ailleurs avec son son missile
visa pas d'appli ils peuvent faire un
gros mp cramer tous les satellites c'est
ça ouais écoute je n'avais pas imaginé
ça mais ouais complètement c'est
d'ailleurs c'est assez marrant parce que
collectivement on tue personne mais on
arrête l'économie pendant un certain
temps de d'une nation ça peut faire
assez mal quoi ce genre de choses
c'était également utilisé
je crois
dans la guerre asymétrique quand les
américains étaient récemment en irak
quand il attaque et surtout jours oui
ils sont toujours quand il a attaqué des
petites villes l'une des choses qui
faisaient assez qu'il arrêtait tout
comme sa question internet n'est-il pas
idéaliste d'imaginer licorne française
alors que les américains rachète les
projets d'avenir ou que les français
partent aux us pour trouver des capitaux
ou non déjà il y en a je pense
aujourd'hui à angers par une fait le
décompte récemment mais je pense qu'il
peut avoir six ou sept il y en avait 2
au début de l'année dernière et mon pari
c'est qu'il y aura bientôt une dca corde
donc 10 milliards alors je vais être un
peu
je sais pas laquelle ça sera mais dans
les récentes de celles qui ont très très
vite augmenter la
g
je sais pas laquelle ça sera mais il y
en a plusieurs que je trouve qu'il
croise tellement vite je me dis wow
c'est quand même assez assez
impressionnant quoi vos questions
internet apprend au fil de notre
interview comment peut-on parler
démocratie quand on sait déjà ce que les
gens vont voter
j'ai pas compris je te le répète comment
peut-on parler de démocratie quand on
sait déjà ce que les gens vont voter
bah non il ya des surprises à chaque
élection donc
non pas chaque fois il se ils font des
plateaux télé jusqu'à 1h du mat parce
qu'il tombe de leur chaise gorille non
mais ça c'est parce qu'ils sont hors sol
ouais d'ailleurs il ya une question qui
va suivre et il n'a t-il pas
l'impression d'être hors sol message ça
ok mais qui viennent le faire quoi enfin
jeu franchement plus le mec qui dit sa
hâte à tort je vous réponde à ça je veux
dire vas-y plan que toi dans ton coin et
regarde son interview effet rien et
continue à faire ça tu vois moi j'essaie
de faire bouger les choses alors
peut-être que je suis un gros naïfs
voilà je lui parle à lui mais j'y passe
une énergie de malade et je vois là au
moins j'aurai essayé quoi
bein y compris le petit goût d'un fin
manteau
revenons on va parler de 5 g
je te lance le sujet comme ça ensuite je
pose des questions la 5g des idées pas
d'idées
si la 5g sait il faut le comprendre
c'est c'est un truc de dingue en fait
c'est que c'est pas que la vitesse est
ce que la 5g est une technologie
déterminante pour l'indépendance
numérique de la france pour qu'on
travaille
ouais ouais ouais si j'ai un petit
problème avec huawei mai
donc moi j'ai travaillé sur ouais j'ai
fait ça se trouve sur la petite histoire
c'est quoi c'est que j'étais avec huawei
avec le management de huawei le
lendemain du jour où trump a annoncé les
mesures j'étais dans le gt dans leur
méga
incroyable extraordinaire lieu center à
tous est nécessaire
non j'étais à shenzhen à shenzhen et
j'étais avec eux et l'égalité qu'à un
peu groggy parce qu'il venait de s'en
prendre une quoi et
moi je suis très doctrine de l'ansea là
dessus c'est que il ya des design qui
permettent de neutraliser les risques
qui sont éviter à tout prix d'avoir des
infrastructures qui appartiennent à
quelqu'un uniquement et avoir un
contrôle
des équipements stratégiques dans les
réseaux voilà donc je m'en tiendra lundi
je suis pas un spécialiste de ces sujets
des architectures de réseaux télécoms
mais je fais confiance à lancy à cet
égard on pourrait revenir sur le web
parce qu'il ya plein d'autres
implications
sur le design des smartphones ou là par
contre c'est très difficile s'il ya une
backdoor de la détecter
également sur un truc que les gens ne
voient pas mais là où ça peut faire le
plus mal c'est pas sur l'interdiction
des smartphones ou sur les
infrastructures c'est sur les kiosques
d'applications serre que si à google se
retire et ne leur donne plus de licence
il ya plus de facebook il ya plus de
twitter il ya plus de je ne sais quoi
c'est fini quoi c'est et ça va être
difficile de vendre le moindre
smartphone en disant tu as tik tok voilà
c'est pour ça
5 j paraît-il que sa vie la 5g alors la
5g donc c'est du débit de la latence je
suis connecté tout partout voilà
effectivement sur ce genre de choses
mais surtout c'est du sauveteur define
network c'est à dire avoir une capacité
pour des opérateurs virtuels de
maîtriser des environnements avec
une maîtrise de la performance de la
distribution de la performance
qui est absolument totale ainsi que de
la sécurité donc c'est comme si on avait
des lan virtuel de façon infinie sur le
réseau qui se baladent et qui vont être
totalement autonome de l'infrastructure
physique voilà ça c'est je crois quelque
chose qu'il faut qu'on monte et les gens
ne comprennent pas comme ça donc les je
sais qu'il ya pas mal de
d'experts qui sont sur cinq heures view
je pense que ça a des implications
effectivement quasi géostratégique qui
sont importantes et me semble-t-il
c'est un boulot qui regardent l'arcep
j'ai
vraiment confiance en sébastien soriano
qui est le patron de l'arcep parce qu'il
a vu ce truc là
il va falloir aussi émettre des
recommandations en matière de
gouvernance de design de référence
d'implémentation
qui sont pros l'an émises dans le cadre
des
dunes et l'administration des licences
qui seront confiées
on parle un peu intelligence
artificielle ou cet ennui
alors moi je suis très
énervé par le côté futur halo qui n'y
connaît rien et qui explique ce que ça
va devenir genre urologue
y en a un certain nombre
certain en prônant dépassé dans la
médecine m&g dire on a pour moi quand je
prends
vraiment les gens qui me semble
intéressant
sur ce sujet qui sont des experts je
parle
le qu'un par exemple voilà c'est
intéressant bon ben il nous ramène
vachement sur terre quand ils me disent
arcaro s'il a fait une déclaration assez
étonnante où il a dit qu' ils pensent
qu'ils verraient de son vivant des
intelligences artificielles
ambiante non ça n'existe pas et ça il
faut arrêter avec ça typiquement ça
m'énerve ça fait l'avocat dit ça
n'existe pas général et machines seront
jamais consciente et jean qui ça ils
sont plus dans le domaine de la science
quand ils sont dans le domaine du délire
et donc ça peut être des sensibilités ça
te parle pas
alors moi j'ai eu une conversation une
fois inquiets nokia dans un déjeuner où
il n'y croyait pas voilà est-ce que
quand il dit d intelligence profonde
livre la dir singularité je ne sais pas
faudrait creuser le truc
artificielle faible intelligence
artificielle forte ouais
bon forte singulière quoi voilà c'est
moi moi ce qui m'intéresse plus c'est
en gros quel est l'état de l'art du
machine learning évidemment du diplôme
ning qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre
quand elon musk diba nous on pense que
on va avoir un véhicule de catégorie 4
qui va circuler prochainement même si
c'est dans trois ans c'est intéressant
ça se regarde quoi ça c'est du concret
et je dirais qu'on est sortis du délire
de à ce que les machines vont tomber
amoureuse ou je sais pas quoi voilà on
est un vrai domaine applicatif quand on
parle
d'avoir des capacités de reconnaissance
faciale faut savoir de quoi on parle
parce que en réalité quand on va
chercher dans une base de plusieurs
millions d'empreintes c'est plus
compliqué que ça ça se passe pas comme
ça directement
on a par exemple un truc moi j'ai
compris quand j'étais en chine donc j'ai
fait une mission d'étude de trois
semaines en chine a donné
ton empreinte faciale en train de tout
court ils ont eu ta photo social reding
je tiendrai thing avec des mots en
français le fait d'être impliqué dans la
rue quand on traverse au feu rouge et
prendre une amende de 1 euro quand on
est sur l'autre trottoir ou même avant
d'ailleurs
j'ai l'impression et ce sera à vérifier
que ça ne marche pas si je n'ai pas de
portable sur moi en tout cas moi j'ai
discuté avec des gens qui sont des
experts du sujet chinois chinois et qui
m'ont dit qu'ils pensaient que ça ne
marchait pas il en était pas certain eux
mêmes
pourquoi parce que si j'ai une base de 1
milliard de personnes derrière
en temps réel ça c'est pas fonctionné
donc ce que ça fait c'est que ça va
faire le rapprochement
voilà c'est compliqué c'est moi ce que
j'ai vu
c'est que même en mettant en alignant
beaucoup de gpu en ayant de la d'attaqué
juste derrière c'est compliqué c'est pas
évident c'est on a ce que l'on me dit
c'est que sur 100 personnes ça va au
delà on commence à voir des gros taux
d'échec voilà et c'est franchement des
gens qui me disent ça sont des gens qui
sont dans le sujet à quoi ça va discuter
un peu du prédictif ou pas du tout tu
vois davantage d'états d'état discuter
un peu du prédictif pas du tout ouais
prédictifs moi je connais des gens qui
en font un par exemple dans la
maintenance
par des gros environnement industriel je
connais des gens qui font ce genre de
choses comme des start up qui travaille
là dessus
c'est de la stat 1 c de la stata très
large échelle
et ça fonctionne c'est un des domaines
d'application qui marche très très bien
voilà typiquement le
prédictif
dans le domaine de la médecine c'est à
dire faire du diagnostic ou du
diagnostic prédictif ça fonctionne pas
encore
pas du tout pas bien pas bien pas bien
quand laurent alexandre dit
l'intelligence artificielle le
diagnostic c'est chez les dermatologues
ça permet d' achat dermato ça marche
générale houleuse les dermatos ça marche
pas mal mais faut voir de quoi on parle
parce que en fait il dit ça et c'est
spectaculaire
mais moi je trouve que j'ai vu les
images et donc
ben on y est enfin au bout d'un quart
d'heure on arrive très bien à dire ça
c'est mélanome ça c'est pas voilà donc
c'est pas c'est pas le truc
extraordinaire quoi oui
les machines y arrive assez bien mais
après la machine qui est complètement
autonome et qui met le médecin chômage
ça c'est son délire quoi on va parler
d'un très vieux problème la neutralité
du net ça en est où
c'est un problème récurrent j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure des sdn
c'est
la 5g c'est la fin de la neutralité du
certaines heures ce jeudi dans une
environnement
écoute toi t'es pas une machine
industrielle prioritaire donc ton petit
chat la de sur what's app et où il passe
derrière quoi et donc telle dégradation
de la qualité on s'est passé comme une
lettre à la poste parce que c'était
porté par la 5g en gros ce truc là il ya
une petite interruption de la neutralité
à cet égard
après je pense que
paradoxalement on a passé
la bosse serre qu'il ya eu un moment où
on parlait de faire des lan virtuelle
dans les environnements physiques
traditionnels et les opérateurs étaient
ados ont fait ce qu'ils disaient on va
faire une offre à
avec la même infrastructure août aura le
droit de faire du wat sa pépite aura pas
le droit de faire du whatsapp si t'as
pas payer un euro de plus ou je sais pas
quoi ça arrive dans certains pays quel
est le pays qui a interdit whatsapp où
ça provoquait je crois que c'est le
cameroun
non non non cameron a dit vous allez
payer 1 euros en plus par mois pour
avoir des voix de sable lydon a ou le
liban voix c'est le liban le liban et
c'est parti
c'est parti assez sérieusement en vrille
là dessus donc c'est un voilà je pense
que malgré tout il ya un cadre qui est à
préserver
une certaine neutralité d'ailleurs c'est
marrant parce que moi je me souviens
très bien que il ya cinq ans je
comprenais pas très bien d'autres
invités de l'humain du net la commission
avait poussé l'idée d'avoir ce qu'ils
appelaient un réseau d'urgence ou un
faisceau d'urgence je pense et c'était
la quadrature du net qui mali mais
attends tu vas pas défendre ce truc là
c'est débile et ça qui m'a expliqué que
c'était une connerie à l'époque et je
m'étais opposé à la commission là dessus
qu'ils haut de toute façon avait laissé
tomber sujet quoi
question internet de juanito que pense j
de la façon dont google a détourné la
loi sur les droits voisins
ouais c'est
compliqué c'est
j'ai pas d'avis très arrêtée là dessus
objectivement et je dis pas ça parce que
j'ai pas envie de me mouiller j'ai
rencontré je dirai pas qui mais le
patron d'un grand groupe de presse est
vraiment un grand groupe de presse il
n'y a pas longtemps
et je lui ai dit et on en a parlé un qui
faisait pas de propagande d'ailleurs
non mais je lui ai dit écoute tu es un
peu de
talent et tu peux porter les deux
casquettes objectivement et il m'a dit
mais j'ai pas la vie j'arrive pas à
avoir un avis c'est d'un côté
les gens de l'internet 10 écoute voilà
une certaine manière c'est du contenu
vous débrouiller on va pas commencer à
taxer le contenu et donc même si c'est
les gaffes en reste sur un modèle
pré commission européenne et puis de
l'autre
ces mecs là met un bordel incroyable
dans un marché et après ils disent oups
je t'ai marché sur les pompes excuse moi
mais en fait je vais me retirer de tout
ça et puis tu vas te démerder
jeu
j'ai pas la vie voilà qu'on vend en
chine sur la prochaine question de saint
ybars life comment peut-on contraint les
gars fin à des lois restrictives en
dépit de leur puissance n'est ce pas
naïf de penser que c'est possible quand
on voit là la taxe
sur les gaffes à ce front démantelé
c'est comme ça pas par les européens par
les américains parce que ils
introduisent tellement distorsion aux
états unis même que à un moment la fcc
le congrès va les couper en morceaux la
question qui se pose est ce une question
un peu technique c'est comment
bénéficier les rendements croissants
et comment éviter les abus de position
dominante et la destruction d'innovation
il ya deux fois moins start up
aujourd'hui que ya quinze ans aux états
unis qui secret et pour le coup il ya
beaucoup plus de pognon qui va dans
l'innovation il va dans le led stage
pourquoi parce qu'on essaie de protéger
ses entreprises des gaffes et donc de
leur permettre d'atteindre une taille
critique qui est tel qu'ils sont plus
atteignables par ces acteurs là voilà
donc on a complètement on s'est retrouvé
à s'adapter un phénomène qui consistait
à dire de toute façon ils sont là ils
sont là pour durer et on se retrouve
dans une position où dans les levées de
fonds aux états unis à une question qui
est bien connue qui s'appelle ouhadi
google dosettes et si on ne sait pas
répondre à cette question on ne lève pas
d'argent et c'est le cas de plainte
start-up j'en connais une moi j'avais
une start up qui voulaient faire des
interphones deux portiers le truc génial
à quoi donc j'arrive j'ai un token que
l'on m'a envoyé sur le web sa part mais
je sais pas quoi qu'ils disent tu as le
droit de rentrer chez moi entre 14h et
16h pour amener ampli parce que tu es la
femme de ménage parce que tu es un pote
voilà il ya un panneau qui dit bienvenue
gilles
l'escalier se trouve le troisième
escaliers tu vas au fond là à droite
avec le ciel mais qu'ils m'expliquent
comment je sors je parcours l'immeuble a
le truc génial la start up c'est chiant
de venir chez toyo c'est chiant de venir
chez moi et la start-up génial tu as qui
avait pensé à tout et c'est
j'en parle à un leveur de fonds non moi
je suis pas ça parce que il ya amazon
qui est en train de le faire amazon
vient avec un truc dix fois moins bien
mais la start up s'est pas fait financer
et à la ferme et voilà et ça ça arrive
tous les jours c'est pas acceptable donc
ces mecs là
je pense que pour plusieurs raisons
parce que c'est une menace sur la
démocratie parce que c'est aujourd'hui
une limitation sur l'innovation
parce que ils ont la capacité de rentrer
sur n'importe quel nouveau domaine et
désintermédiés les acteurs qui sont
dessus sont trop gros et doivent être
contrôlés j'espère que techniquement les
régulateurs me donnant raison aux
grosses des doigts autre question
internet grâce où en est le projet
artemis le pas de tir à la française
impliquant la dg des douanes thales
systran bertin se voulant être un
écosystème bourg et d'intelligence
artificielle et de big data moi moi
perso je crois pas du tout à ses mécanos
industriels je pense que les chats font
pas des chiens et que les grandes
entreprises ça va faire des innovations
de rupture
quelles seraient les conséquences d'une
décroissance subie de long terme sur le
numérique
une décroissance écologique j'imagine et
économique oui mais induite par
l'écologie c'est induite par une
une baisse de capacité à avoir accès à
d'énergie facile ou des choses comme ça
je sais pas j'ai part affiché à ça
mais en tout cas c'est sûr que
notre modèle il est pas tenable quoi il
est juste pape c'est juste dingue que ce
soit pas évident c'est à dire qu' il ya
des tas de gens qui disent moi si je
doit consommer moins je suis pas
d'accord comme tu gagnes
bah moi c'est un peu particulier parce
que j'ai gagné pas mal d'argent dans le
passé donc une partie de mes revenus qui
n'ont pas mal
je ne dis pas mais j'ai vendu une start
up 100 millions d'euros et j'avais un
tout petit bout de ça voilà un
donc mais je vis un petit peu
partiellement là dessus et puis je gagne
un petit peu ma vie à côté en faisant
des missions de conseil stratégique du
coup un petit peu
celui-ci composent l'udc estime moi
c'est moi j'ai pas envie de donner mes
revenus mais je gagne convenablement ma
vie quoi j'ai très peu de clients je
fais du conseil stratégique généralement
auprès des six ans et j'adore ça je
trouve ça super intéressant et je
choisis mes clients en fonction de leurs
capacités à faire l'impact
sociétal oui bien sûr environnemental
sociétal
c'est rare où ça commence à se
généraliser dans les airs moi j'ai des
clients et qui je suis très heureux
voilà et j'en ai pas beaucoup nous
annonce ne faut pas le dire parce qu'en
plus je suis dans une situation de
manteaux ring de gens qui sont connus
non ça je le dis pas
je repasse une question est-ce que tu un
ami imaginaire ce que tu crois en
quelque chose que tu crois en dieu ce
que tu
[Musique]
as à l'écran des images hier alors moi
je suis très spiritualiste faire je suis
un dieu le barbu l'a pas trop mais je
je pense que en fait c'est presque du
était un homme et voilà donc c'est ce
que je dis je pense c'est presque une
posture scène d'un point de vue
scientifique c'est à dire que
je me suis beaucoup intéressé à
l'épistémologie et les épiceries et les
secours aux scientifiques aux 6-10 ans
fait la posture raisonnable c'est plus
de croire à l'absence de limitation que
la limitation est là
finalement l'athéisme est une posture de
limitation donc je serai agnostique à
cet égard il se trouve que j'ai plutôt
un penchant spiritualiste assez prononcé
je suis un militant je fais une heure et
demie de méditation chaque jour
c'est essentiel dans ma vie et j'ai une
expérience personnelle un peu
particulière qui mais plutôt dans cette
dimension la
question de moules frites ait
et si on nationalise les gros acteurs du
numérique ça lui irait un google france
avec des ministres aux bandes ou du coup
ça devient orwellien alors c'est
friedman je crois thomas friedman qui a
vous a mis dans la merde en ce moment là
non non non non fellmann n'est pas de
ceux qui nous ont mis en berne en ce
moment mais qui a dit à une époque
non c'est stiglitz pendant ces stiglitz
qui a dit hamilton alan minton nous a
mis dans la merde alchemy monétariste
effectivement mais on peut importe
stiglitz adif joseph qu'on a reçus il ya
pas très longtemps ah je ne savais pas
assez dément et il a dit en fait suivant
les critères qui ont été
définis par la doctrine de la
concurrence donc quand elle a été créée
en 1923 avec la standard oil on devrait
démanteler les cafards et on devrait en
faire d utilité publique
parce que c'est en fait des services
publics j'ai trouvé que c'était et ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'il a
structuré cette réflexion il a fait ça
je crois avec ses élèves je crois qu'il
est profané noailles ou harvard et ils
ont défini le cadre dans lequel cela
pourrait se faire j'avais lu le résumé
tout ça j'avais trouvé ça amusant ce que
tu connais bien tenir en question de
filou 88 ouais je sais trop noir pour
moi j'ai vu la première saison je crois
a plus jamais arrêté que pense-t-il
commissaire en paix thierry breton
ça c'est
en fait je vois je vais être cash c'est
un type
vraiment brillant mais franchement c'est
hardcore de se taper quoi sert il a des
opinions sur tout voilà comme ça je peux
et je devrais pas dire ça parce que je
vais être amené à rencontrer donc ça va
me prendre un peu la porte mais c'est un
mec qui sait tout et qui a une opinion
sur tout et qui est quand même vraiment
smart quoi quand il dit que même si
l'issue du monde de l'entreprise il va
couper tout lien avec
ag pas de débat là dessus j'en suis sûr
il a été ministre de l'économie et je
connais des gens qui étaient dans son
cabinet et qui ont dit il a été
impeccable là-dessus
lobbying dans le numérique
non tu veux en parler excuse et du
lobbying auprès des états ce que
beaucoup moins qu'on croit à la
commission c'est un truc qui m'a frappé
ce qu'on dit tablettes microsoft dans
les écoles
ouais
c'est très visible c'est très débile et
il devrait pas faire ça ça sert pas leur
intérêt
très très bonne question
je suis
sont paumés quoi il faut comprendre les
affaires publiques ces gars là ils ont
perdu le tempo ils n'ont eu pendant des
années il arriver à poser des mémos sur
les bureaux des commissaires en dix ans
voulait faire du cloud c'est comme ça
qu'il faut faire et comme il avait les
meilleurs experts au monde il y arriver
ils ont perdu le tempo ils ont vraiment
perdu
alors question de à 31 si la chine peut
manipuler 50% des deux est ce que la
chine assure ne pas corrompre la chaîne
pour lui faire perdre toute sa valeur on
parle de
huit corps humain
ouais mais ça se verrait immédiatement
donc il offrait il fera un coup il sera
d'ailleurs il s'appropriera du truc tout
le monde ne verrait tout le monde dirait
c'est les chinois soit
je suis en train de piocher dans les
questions
la rgpp des
est elle selon vous une oie suffisantes
actuellement non elle a plein de défauts
à l'hérésie défaut d'abord prenez
trubert gpd c'est qu'il ya pas de x on
aurait dû dire voilà il ya une unique ce
qui est obligé pour ce type de cookies
le bouton il est vers ce type de cookies
il est orange et vous êtes capable de le
régler depuis votre navigateur
pour la totalité des sites que vous
allez visiter voilà et là ces codes à ce
lot de l'as lessing moi j'ai beaucoup
pousser ça je leur ai dit arrêtez de
faire du droit habitable que 95% des
gens on va dépenser une énergie énorme
pour comprendre ce truc là les tpe pme
vont galérer comme des malades c'est
exactement ce qui est en train de se
passer donc ça c'est un premier point et
puis il ya plein de sujets que ça couvre
pas moi je pense que leur gpd par
exemple qui devrait définir la capacité
d'accéder à ces données dans les
plateformes en temps réel on devrait
avoir formalisé une api les cloud on
devra avoir formalisé une api on devrait
pouvoir être capable de dire écoute azur
j'en ai marre je vais aller sur le
quat'sous 1
openstack a fort à formaliser une api
elle vous est imposée et je bouge voilà
ça ça aurait été super faut le faire on
doit le faire et on doit faire une v2 du
rgp n'est l'invité at il eu le livre la
fabrique du crétin digital et comment
voit-il le digital dans le système
éducatif
je laisse sur ma table de nuit je n'ai
pas lu
alors c'est compliqué les gîtes à
l'indicatif pourquoi c'est compliqué
parce qu'on est en train de mettre la
dernière main un rapport aux senim sur
ce sujet et on est dans la phase où
on auditionne le ministère pour qu'il
nous dise qu'est ce qu'ils font dans le
cadre de ce rapport pour pouvoir
l'aménager voilà je après je peux avoir
des déclarations absolue
je vais le faire d'ailleurs
ce que je pense du samedi katif c'est
que c'est un mammouth pour reprendre la
déclaration du d'un ancien ministre qui
a mal fini d'ailleurs
et que on peut pas parler de statut
absolue sans parler du la stratégie de
changement donc je pourrais dire il
faudrait que tout le système éducatif ce
soit une grande école montessori c'est
réaliste voilà et le mit je pourrais
même dire j'ai connu blanc caire à
l'époque où il était collaborateur à
l'institut montaigne et il trouvait ça
une super bonne idée sauf que maintenant
il a les mains dans le truc il doit le
faire et que c'est l'enfer voilà donc
jeu
il ya une initiation au code c'est bien
elle va être obligatoire pour tout le
monde à partir de cette année c'est bien
aussi ça va être galère parce qu'il
faudra former des profs en plus à quel
code ces questions mais c'est déjà ça
quoi c'est c'est toujours le problème
avec le l'éducationnationale c'est que
c'est tellement galère de bouger ce truc
là que en fait en gros soit on est face
à des gens qui comprennent et qui
polarise les énergies dans la bonne
direction
j'ai une tendance on va voir ce que les
auditions qu'on fait font ressortir mais
j'ai tendance à penser que ça va plutôt
dans ce sens là voilà en revanche là où
ça foire mais vraiment massivement c'est
l'enseignement supérieur on est planté
et c'est complètement
c'est pas possible voilà donc si j'ai
une critique à faire à l'égard du
gouvernement c'est celle ci s'est on
ajuste planté le truc sert qu'on a été
incapable la meilleure initiative cette
initiative privée ses 42 voilà et
aujourd'hui avec ses défauts avec ses
défauts bien sûr mais toute adhésion des
fous des fossés que
les softs qu'ils y en a pas quoi donc il
arrive enfin moi j'ai des expériences le
démontre quoi j'ai un copain qui
recrutent deux personnes de 42 il ya un
mec au bout de jeu pas trois semaines il
va voir ce gala et l'immédiat sens que
tu fasses est nul je vais aller parler
au patron je vais lui expliquer et puis
voilà et s'il comprend pas je me casse
voilà texto à et c'est un peu le
tropisme de 42 c'est un peu le problème
c'est que les mecs se prennent pour des
stars beaucoup ils n'ont pas été formés
en sauf qu'ils à savoir comment ça
marche une boîte et ça continue quand
même encore un peu donc sophie nouvelle
patronne elle fait un boulot
extraordinaire génial sur le genre sur
plein de trucs et c'est pour ça que
c'est toujours directional c'est
compliqué ça change doucement ça va dans
la bonne direction sont toujours aussi
fille qui à 42 ou non
ça a été débranchée par sophie elle est
arrivée à la débrancher le truc voilà
donc maintenant je pense qu'ils sont un
système en coin le flicage là chez eux
bah c'était par exemple les caméras de
sécurité tout le monde pouvait y accéder
déjà pour commencer et on pouvait le
wind effacé quand même assez fort quoi
sur ce truc là et il y avait du croît de
façon délibérée
des failles que tout le monde pouvait
franchir pour aller voir ce que
faisaient les autres et c'est donc et ça
moi j'ai bien connu les fondateurs de 42
je pense que c'était un peu leur logique
un peu
de
franchisseur de ligne jaune d'avocats
plus à quoi
le 26 février babini sur l'enseignement
supérieur
donc aujourd'hui un codeur
soi-disant foule stack qui a fait deux
années formation supérieure ou pas
d'ailleurs il va avoir tout de suite un
premier job entre quarante et cinquante
mille euros voilà il va avoir quatre ou
cinq offres et c'est en train de
s'empirer et au delà de ça on n'a pas
repenser les curriculum de l'ensemble de
l'université si je prends par exemple
un statisticien voilà quelqu'un qui fait
la statistique publique al n'diaye bah
tout c'est logique de machine learning
de big data de
ce que j'appellerais la roue data c'est
à dire de la data qui n'est pas
structurée qui va venir
d'une antenne bts qui peut venir des
réseaux sociaux du lexical de wikipédia
qui a beaucoup de valeur en termes de
statistiques publiques ils savent pas
s'en servir ils sont restés au xxème
siècle dans la façon dont ils font des
régression linéaire sur la data qui a
été construite par eux et c'est
même chose si vous faites la géographie
être capable d'avoir une formation au
big data pour pouvoir comprendre des
cartes
voilà ça c'est un truc moi je pense que
ça n'a pas été fait on a des universités
qui sont déliquescence qui s'enfonce
dans les classements internationaux
et je sais que je vais me faire allumer
pour avoir dire ça mais c'est la réalité
et le pire c'est que la ou des trucs qui
deviennent quasiment des normes dans
beaucoup de monde qui sont finalement
des frais d'inscription en fonction des
revenus des parents qui sont quand même
assez républicain je trouve qui
permettrait de financer une partie du
système
c'est des trucs qu'on on met en l'air
quoi refuse de voir moi j'ai pas de
problème de faire payer des gens qui
viennent de pays riches voilà alors
c'est pas populaire ok mais moi je pense
ça je pense que les gens qui viennent de
pays pose pas pareil et voilà et je
pense que la gouvernance universitaire
c'est une blague voilà c'est un truc il
ya tout le monde ya le patron
des services généraux et puis finalement
on se retrouve à avoir des mecs qui font
de l'autre duo tiède et c'est comme ça
que sont gérés les universités je vais
vraiment me faire allumer pour nissan
mais je le pense profondément
je pense que le premier acte républicain
c'est de permettre d'avoir un truc
qu'ils soient de bonne qualité et qui
soit pas uniquement que quantitatif donc
il faut réformer ça et ce boulot n'est
pas fait et ça nous pénalisera si on
veut devenir une start up nation il n'y
a pas de grands pays numérique qui est
pas un système d'excellence donc il y en
a 3 4 il ya les états unis il est pas
équitable mais il est excellent il
concentre tout le capital humain qui
produit de la recherche numérique si je
prends ta éducation si je prends les 50
meilleurs computer school il y en a 38
qui je crois sont aux etats unis une
valeur 8 qui sont en chine non il y en a
six qui sont en chine il y en a huit qui
sont en europe et il y en a deux qui
sont en europe continentale u16 qui sont
au royaume uni voilà il faut monter dans
ce classement le 26 février 2013 gilles
babinet accorde une interview magazine
l'usiné nouvelle dans lequel il déclare
que la cnil est un ennemi de la nation
je l'est totalement assumée
web à la cnil à l'époque était dans une
logique
d'empêcher les choses auxerre quoi et on
était c'était très compliqué
d'innover parce que
voilà je pense par exemple à
l'épidémiologie donc les datas de santé
on pouvait rien faire mais qu'il y avait
un changement de destination de données
c'était pas possible c'était aussi
peut-être pour protéger tout ça non oui
mais il faut choisir il faut un juste
milieu il faut comprendre d'un côté et à
l'innovation
de l'autre côté il ya la nouvelle
innovation et la protection totale voilà
et entre les deux il ya un juste milieu
il ya la voie du milieu et c'est celle
là qu'il faut choisir et cette loi d'une
voie du milieu c'était clairement pas
celle du lac meech a beaucoup évolué
sous le mandat d'isabelle falque
pierrotin donc la même présidente qui
était trop coercitives quand même
redresser le tir voilà et puis
maintenant on a le verger [__] qui crée un
cadre ferme c'est beaucoup plus stable
beaucoup plus cohérent qui fait beaucoup
de l'autre une image auris prudence mais
qui a le mérite d'exister on va parler
de censure numérique
question de filou 88 encore quel est le
niveau de censure numérique en france
est-ce que
la privatisation de la police numérique
par les gars femmes c'est une des
missions de l'état c'est parce que
l'état sait pas faire c'est parce que
l'étape en sont sûrs et aussi c'est pas
possible quoi c'est vraiment
moi moi je pense que
cette histoire de
l'article 11 qui est devenu article 15
si je me trompe pas
c'est dommage quoi c'était l'occasion
de mettre les algorithmes du côté de
l'état en fait alors que là aujourd'hui
on a dit écoutez il ya plein de trucs
c'est trop compliqué donc on va définir
un cadre vous allez gérer
dans quels cas on débranche dans
quelqu'un on interdit et cetera
et puis on prendra que les gros trucs
mais moi je pense qu'il y avait tout un
tas de cas intermédiaires il ya eu dans
la foulée une journaliste dont j'ai
oublié le nom qui sent qu'elle ait fait
d'être speechi sans qu'elle ait fait de
quoi que ce soit elle s'y retrouver
banide twitter pendant un certain temps
après son compte a été rétablie c'est
ouf une journaliste quoi c'est pas
normal et donc moi je crois que en gros
il ya des cas qui peuvent être laissés à
facebook mais peu en fait qu'ils sont
les cas vraiment très généraux traités
par des algorithmes mais qui nécessite
un auditeur externe
exactement comme les comptes d'une
entreprise sont certifiés
et donc on peut avoir un contrôle sur la
façon dont on certifie il faut une
transparence des algorithmes qui sont
accessibles à l'auditeur
voilà et puis il faut commencer à avoir
un parquet numérique c'est-à-dire avoir
même plus d'ailleurs avoir un système
judiciaire dans son ensemble
qu'ils soient numériques il sera capable
d'absorber des algorithmes et de se
prononcer lui-même et non pas de dire
amenez-moi ex ante et le cas et je vous
dirai si c'est bon ou pas voilà ça c'est
voilà encore une fois on en revient sur
le fait que la justice est très peu
financés mais le numérique c'est en
train de devenir partout et donc il faut
que la justice le comprennent et
comprennent le coeur de ses algorithmes
et soient capables de se prononcer
c'est les juges qui sont les garants des
libertés publiques
donc c'est à eux de le faire
donc le cynisme s'est prononcé sur la
haine sur le sur internet c'est ça
qu'est ce qui a émergé tout ça c'est un
peu ce que je suis en train de dire
d'ailleurs en passant mais on va se
prononcer là dessus on va continuer à le
faire on a une commission permanente qui
a été créé sur liberté parce qu'on s'est
dit c'est un sujet qui tellement énorme
que il faut que quelqu'un ne s'occupe de
ça
et donc c'est
théodore je sais jamais dire son nom
titicaca kiss qui s'occupe de ça qui est
vraiment un type incroyable quoi qui a
une vraiment et encore une fois tout à
l'heure j'ai évoqué l'importance du
droit
parfois ils m'agacent presque tant il
dit à temps il faut être capable de
l'expliquer en droit sciences et pas
l'expliquer endroit on est dans
l'arbitraire et je trouve ça enfin je
trouve ça extrêmement élégant et
extrêmement louable
aux questions internet laine cyr élèves
relève du breil ministre et s'occupe des
infrastructures informatiques de
l'assemblée nationale et des tribunaux
cela ne pose-t-il pas un souci dans la
séparation des pouvoirs et l'accès à
l'information entre parenthèses un
ministre ayant accès à un dossier
informatique mots etc ne faut-il pas une
organisation beaucoup plus indépendante
que l'anzhi alors l'ansi pourquoi on la
rattacher au prince parce qu'on voulait
quelque chose qui soit opérationnel
rapidement il y avait un vrai enjeu de
deux souverains de wight souveraineté on
peut le dire comme ça et leur
attachement au premier ministre c'est ce
qu'il ya de plus efficace
quand vous avez un arbitrage à faire que
vous avez une administration par exemple
qui y voit la sécurité ça m'intéresse
pas trop mais c'est assez facile d'aller
saisir le cabinet du premier ministre
dire tiens eu comme un me freine un peu
des pieds serait bien que tu leur donnes
un coup de fil et puis qu'on débloque
c'est ce qui s'est passé et après je
pense que le problème c'est pas tant
d'avoir une annecy qui continuent à être
rattaché au premier ministre que d'avoir
des systèmes d'arbitrage et une
gouvernance qui peut-être peu à peu vont
être confiées au pouvoir judiciaire
typiquement je suis pas là ici se
retrouva
pas savoir s'il faut qualifier une
action d'agression ou d'être un enjeu de
liberté de l'information bah il faut
qu'ils aient un juge qui soit pas loin
qui soit capable de qualifier ce genre
de choses
on arrive à la fin notre interview est
ce que tu vois des sujets sur lesquels
on n'a pas traité
tu vas être exprimés
en
[Musique]
fait moi je suis venu ici en sachant
très bien que je serais vachement
attendu sur le sujet des libertés parce
que les gens pour parler un peu cash
comme j'ai été nommé président du
conseil national numérique par sarkozy
ils pensent que je suis un sarkozy boy
ce que j'ai jamais été oui à sarko boy
voilà c'est ça et donc d'ailleurs la
quadrature il me regardait un peu de
traviole à l'époque c'était assez
marrant
reste que je t'ai du dragon château oui
je me souviens la première fois qu'on
s'est vus tu veux dire chez toi et chez
moi tu m'a dit je vais te défoncer gp tu
lis je me tâte et les jeunes et ouais
c'est ça
[Musique]
bon ok donc moi je veux répondre là
dessus mais il ya un autre terrain je
trouve qui est vraiment important dans
lequel je pense qu'on a un peu moins
discuté c'est comment est ce qu'on fait
un état moderne comment est ce qu'on
fait un état du 21e siècle comment est
ce qu'on fait un état plate forme qui
soit pas reliant et moi trois mois je
m'engage là dedans parce que en
particulier
le sentiment que j'ai c'est que l'état
républicain peut être assurée par les
plateformes il ya des tas de gens qui
sont en dehors des services publics
notamment à diagonale du vide et je
pense que s'ils ont fait ça bien on va
les chercher voilà je trouve que c'est
dommage qu'on n'ait pas parlé de
transport dans les territoires accès à
la santé malte en bas ok super en
transports ou du territoire ben voilà
transports mobilité
territoriale égale mobilité sociale si
je peux plus bouger j'ai plus de chances
de pouvoir changer de deux statues de
situation voilà et si les 80 kilomètres
heure ça fait péter les plombs aux gens
c'est parce qu'ils ont compris ça nous
ça va moi c'est ressorti très très fort
quand j'ai fait des auditions de gilet
jaune en fait j'ai fait un travail et
montagne là dessus
et donc il ya eu une loi l'homme qui
visaient notamment les sujets étaient
des transports aujourd'hui on efface ça
va arriver assez vite à une révolution
qu'on voit d'ailleurs arriver les petits
trottinette ou ces trucs là c'est c'est
un truc subit finalement les
institutions publiques qu'ils disent
mais on n'a pas vu ce truc-là débarqué
on a fait des velits des trucs comme ça
on va voir arriver une deuxième bague
qui va être des systèmes de mobilité
semi autonome public ou enfin comment
dire non pas publiques partagées
et je pense qu'il faut qu'on ait une
réflexion en amont sur comment on
intègre ce truc là pour que ce soit
utilisé par tout le monde
et ces trucs là sont pas très loin de
nous moi je vois des start-up indienne
américaine allemande qui bossent sur ces
sujets là et je pense que ça mériterait
d'avoir une vraie réflexion citoyenne
qui partent notamment des territoires
pour commencer à reconstruire ça et ça
commence avoir lieu notamment plus dans
les conseils généraux qu'au niveau de
l'état accès à la santé
accès à la santé
c'est une vraie opportunité c'est à dire
que
on a un vrai souci d'indépendance on va
claquer 4 à 5% du pib dans la dépendance
le sujet s'est pas uniquement de faire
en sorte que les gens restent chez eux
c'est que il continue à avoir des liens
sociaux ils puissent avoir accès à des
services culturels
et ça sent qu'on leur dise écouter à
votre territoire et les foutus vous
allez devoir bouger pour faire ce truc
là il y avait 20 ans on avait créé un
organisme qui s'appelait la datar qui
existe toujours d'ailleurs qu'ils
avaient un peu cette mission
prince est que la datar elle un peu raté
la révolution numérique et donc il faut
vraiment qui est je pense moi j'aimerais
beaucoup qu'ils aient une forme de débat
citoyen ce n'est pas le grand débat
macro nice qui est pas les gilets jaunes
qui viennent casser tout et tout ça
qu'ils soient un peu plus joli casse
rien
non non violent parce que je veux dire
c'est un débat qui soit du design
thinking je le dis comme ça parce que
moi ce que j'ai vu des gilets jaunes
c'était pas du design thinking des jeux
j'ai vu ce que tout le monde a lu j'ai
vu des mecs qui venaient étaient tous à
paris tu vois ça c'est pour les joutes
qui vit et péter tous
écoute
peut-être mais en tout cas ce dont je
parle c'est d'aller chercher des gens
des territoires qui représente les gens
des territoires et kiko construisent de
politiques publiques voilà et il ya peu
de gens qui font ça encore aujourd'hui
les auditions des gilet jaune ça
consiste en quoi cet effet pourquoi
c'était pour enfin comprendre quoi
en fait la commande qui m'avait passé la
cie montagne c'est la relation entre
gilet jaune et numérique bon c'était un
peu provost et tout ça et donc j'ai
attrapé les gens dans les rues et je
leur fais moi je attrapé les gilets
jaunes des gens qui portaient des gilets
jaunes ont été chercher les chercher où
coup en bas de chez moi donc avec tous
les mieux qu'on peut imaginer parce que
c'est pas un échantillon etc mais voilà
c'était comme ça et ça a fait ressortir
systématiquement un truc incroyable
c'est on ne veut pas de numérique
m'ont dit non non on veut pas numérique
pourquoi parce que il ya un gars qui m'a
enfin je peux vous raconter des
anecdotes sans fond mais les gars qui me
dit écoute tu te raconter permis
conduire tu commences par t'inscrire sur
une plate forme c'est l'enfer tu mets
trois quarts d'heure à faire le parcours
parce que c'est super mal foutu et tout
ça comme au début ils avaient fait un
autre nom oui voilà exactement ces mêmes
trucs pareils puis à la fin on dit va
chercher ton permis à la sous-préfecture
qui à trente bornes parce qu'on a fermé
l'antenne locale
ça pour moi c'est pas du numérique c'est
pas ce truc et puis à plein de gens qui
disent mais c'est vachement compliqué
j'arrive pas à le faire s'est même les
impôts en c1 et en fait ce que ce que je
crois c'est qu'il faut repenser les
politiques publiques à l'aune du
numérique et se dire en fait l'exigence
qu'on doit avoir les gens c'est de faire
en sorte que ce soit plus simple plus
efficace plus équitable qu'à l'époque où
il y avait des guichets
ils y jouent ils ont fait remonter quoi
d'autre qu'est ce que tu penses de
laâyoune c'est déjà un gros truc pour
pour moi les gilets jaunes telles que je
les ai vécues ces les représentants de
la diagonale du vide alors c'est plus
que ça il ya des gilets jaunes qui est
net ville qui était à l'extérieur de ce
genre de choses
mais en gros il ya un travail
fantastique qui a été fait par
yann algan sur ce sujet qui a fait le
livre là-dessus et qui montre que il ya
toute une
énorme espace territorial les villes de
taille moyenne la ruralité vidéo blanche
oui les zones blanches etc où les gens
ont perdu espoir il voit plus la vie de
leurs enfants être mieux meilleure que
la leur ils voient plus leur vie
s'améliorer et ils en ont marre et c'est
vrai en fait ce qui se passe pour ces
gens-là reitz et des gens qui se
retrouvent dans une situation très
cellulaire dans typiquement par exemple
nord-est de la france
c'est
voilà ces trucs cellulaire serre on part
on n'est pas intégré dans sa famille
bien on a plus de filet social qui va
nous aider à rebondir qui sont ses
voisins ses amis sa famille etc
les réseaux sociaux nous ont renforcé
notre isolation on n'a pas des bons jobs
on est dans des zones de forte
désindustrialisation etc etc je pourrais
continuer là-dessus et même si
finalement on a un salaire qui est
potentiellement un peu supérieur à la
moyenne du salaire national qui est
assez basse quand même coup bien mais si
sucroît mills 1550 il me semble et bien
c'est très bas voilà et donc il faut
profiter de la révolution numérique pour
dire à ces gens là on va ces 22 millions
de personnes 1 on va faire des trucs
pour vous on n'a pas fait les machines à
voter tu y crois tu y crois pas
alors en estonie ça marche mais c'est un
des rares domaines et je vois que henri
verdier qui est l'ambassadeur français
du numérique est assez d'accord avec moi
là dessus c'est un des rares domaines où
j'ai des réserves sur le numérique parce
que une balade box une belle boxe je
suis pas comme on dit en france y
ajouter une machine à voter ben on peut
raconter derrière quoi c'est transparent
les petits bouts de papier tout ça
parle pas de machine à mater par une
urne urd union pardon à voilà et donc
après l'intérêt d'avoir une plateforme
numérique c'est qu'on peut faire du
référendum tout le temps quoi donc c'est
parce que c'est compliqué quand même de
dire ça en papier pour tout le monde
donc démocratie participative numérique
c'est ça ouais j'aurais tendance à nîmes
le pouce
le saignement tant que tel je sais pas
moi je pense que oui c'est souhaitable
une question m quelles sont ses rapports
avec le medef abord
mais qui est derrière toi
aucun
enfin je connais geoffroy roux de
bézieux je l'estimé meneur
mais c'est tout j'ai pas de rapport avec
le medef je n'appartiens à rien au medef
[Musique]
toute chose à attendre de lui que nous
non l'europe on n'a pas parlé d'europe
du tout on va parler d'éthique et en
entre les lignes on a quand même pas mal
parler d'éthique mais on peut en parler
on commence par l'europe on enchaîne par
les tic voilà donc
il ya pas mal de gens qui me disent
l'europe c'est un vieux truc et c'est
l'europe elle fait infléchir les gars
fin c'est le seul truc qui arrive
les amendes de 5 milliards les
remboursements de 17 milliards une
broutille
parce qu'on n'a pas encore fait plus
mais pour le moment les gaffes a
les pires pain qui se sont pris ils
venaient de l'europe cinq trams c'était
un peu énervé ouais et puis au delà de
ça un espace de 400 millions de
consommateurs
et citoyens d'ailleurs ça pèse voilà et
donc notre espace de jeu c'est ça si on
veut réussir à créer un espace qui est
différente ce qui se passe en chine et
aux états unis
notre seul espace de jeu c'est l'europe
et donc si les gens me disent ouais mais
en fait que dalle c'est technocratique
et tout ça on va se replier sur la
france c'est l'abandon la capacité de
préserver la souveraineté je peux pas le
dire autrement
il ya une question qui revient souvent
là en ce moment snowdon à son âge
moi j'ai pas la même perception de l'un
et de l'autre
pour des questions pour moi ce ne donne
c'est une sorte de saint numérique un
type extraordinaire beaucoup de respect
pour lui
assange un comportement plus compliqué
c'est sûr qu'ils méritent pas ce qui lui
arrive
mais c'est moins en terme d'intégrité
morale je suis plus ne donne que la sage
pourquoi macron lui a pas donné l'asile
moi j aurais espéré ça je suis pas
macron on peut faire pression sur macro
bas on a beaucoup fait quand il a
demandé moi je
fais passer de trois messages
je connais plein de gens je connais des
gens qui on les rend très élevé dans le
dans l'état était d'accord avec ça
on vient nous poser des questions
pourquoi l'arrêt du ch est sûre thinker
view sur you tube la camisa numérique
non c'est parce qu'il y avait trop de
cinglés
quoi l'accord on a coupé le chat sur
youtube parce que ça c'était c'était
page et c'était pas bien
comment résister à la bulle
algorithmique
audit habilité open source pour
commencer
facebook bon courage
mois google bon courage mais
ça va je
moi je pense qu'il peut y avoir par
exemple
dans les smartphones typiquement il peut
y avoir un framework
qui est scellé donc
on n'a pas le code source
mais il doit y avoir toute une partie
par exemple ce fait serait cognition et
tout ça on doit pouvoir avoir de l'audi
stabilité là dessus que pense-t-il des
solutions open source dans le digital
public question de robes
tout doit être open source dans le
public
l'ordinateur quantique de chez google
j'ai pas la vie je suis pas un expert je
lit plein de trucs comme tout le monde
ça a l'air extraordinaires
pour faire du déchiffrement
aussi mais
je vous venir sur bien sûr c'est sûr que
ça va être un problème je sais pas
peut-être déjà depuis des années mais on
ne sait pas prêt c'est possible c'est
possible je pense pas parce que vu
comment on les galères et puis c'est
quand même de la science et la science
est assez ouverte quand même arrivé à
cacher ça ce serait fort c'est quoi les
liens entre l'institut montaigne et le
medef on n'a pas
écouté il ya tellement de questions a
arrêté
un truc qui remercie parce que souvent
des questions super pertinente mais qui
on a passé beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
questions pour cette interview le
transhumanisme une petite dernière comme
ça là d un avis
c'est pas mon truc c'est un c'est pas
mon sujet et en plus moi je crois
profondément à
à l'humain
ça me fait marrer quoi c'est un
quand je vois kurt weill qui prend des
médicaments toutes les trois minutes
qu'a l'air malheureux comme une pierre
et qui nous explique que c'est le futur
ça me fait marrer ou pas
est ce que tu penses que la silicon
valley est ce que tu penses que la
californie c'est devenu une grosse secte
ouais c'est une grosse actes nécessaires
c'est quand même un truc
moi j pas cacher mes critiques sur les
gaffes à je pense que là encore je dis
clairement ce que j'en pensais et
finalement pas beaucoup de gens qui se
disent à qui on une figure publique qui
le disent aussi cache quoi voilà et puis
ça me retourne mine de rien je me prends
quand même des balles des gens ne se
rendent pas compte mais c'est pas
évident c'est il ya plein de trucs que
je suis plus invités mais peu importe
comment non je dirais pas quoi mais je
vois des trucs qui arrive
je suis pas complètement naïf non plus
quoi mais voilà et mais de l'autre côté
avoir un truc où les mecs sont dingues
et vont dire attends mais pourquoi on ne
ferait pas si on faisait un ordinateur
quantique et puis si on mettait 100
millions là dedans c'est génial quoi
c'est juste génial et je trouve que
d'abord un espace où on peut faire ça
c'est super quoi tu pense qu'en france
on a appris et nos élites à formuler à
chaque fois une réponse négative
mais nos élites c'est nous je suis
désolé de le dire c'est les mêmes mecs
c'est nous et quand
je sais pas en bâche un tel parce qu'il
n'a pas un comportement présidentiel ou
je sais pas quoi mais finalement ça veut
dire qu'on aime bien avoir des monarques
et litres comme ça et que c'est nous et
voilà et les gens qui disent ouais c'est
un candide et tout ça m'est venu et
[__] venez faire c'est changer le truc
est impliqué bureau politique c'est je
peux pas dire autre chose
beaucoup de questions
bon on arrive à la fin notre interview
il faut nous donner trois bouquins à
lire et un conseil pour les jeunes
générations
bon un bout que je viens de lire qui n
énorme bouquin en anglais mais qui m'a
complètement stupéfait c'est mou du ch
alors c'est pas du tout mon truc ça pour
moi c'est de la bouillie pour chat les
trois ou les quatre gp plus aucun
intérêt vraiment cessé je suis désolé je
sais que les vos auditeurs sont
passionnés de ces bouquins non un truc
beaucoup plus profond et en fait aux
maux des us ça s'appuie sur ses bouquins
c'est the rise and fall of reach nation
paul kennedy c'est extraordinaire
vraiment et on voit la répétition des
erreurs des nations incroyable c'est
vraiment
après moi j'ai un truc bien
un truc qui s'appelle c'est passionnant
sur mon blog c'est le seul truc qui est
intéressant dans mon blog donc gilles
babinet points comme cela je c'est
passionnant je donne plein de bouquins à
lire
voilà donc
après j'oublie ça assez vite les
bouquins en fait moi j tout un volet de
ma vie où je ne commande pas les
bouquins qui sont là dessus qu'ils sont
plus des bouquins
de philo
d'épistémologie ramon
j'ai lu les bouquins beaucoup de
bouquins de gaston bachelard en
épistémologie je suis pas sûr que ça
passionne les auditeurs mais comprendre
là la nature des sciences pourquoi je
suis critique à l'égard de kurzel ou de
harari
parce que c'est pas des scientifiques et
qui sont pas rigoureux sur la façon dont
ils construisent leurs prédictions du
futur
et je trouve que c'est problématique
d'avoir des implications philosophiques
aussi forte sans avoir une construction
solide
doutre
bachelard
voilà il a écrit pas mal de bouquins sur
par exemple le bouquin que je viens de
lire c'est la construction de l'esprit
scientifique
c'est très dur
mais passionnant quoi un conseil pour
les jeunes générations
fait de la méditation
quel type plein de confiance
gilles babinet merci merci beaucoup
[Musique]